Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、免广告收听、提前解锁系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Adobe Express 赞助播出，这是一款简单快捷、能创作万物的应用程序。这代表着什么？比如说，你需要制作一个演示文稿、视频、社交媒体帖子或传单，对某些人来说——尤其是对我而言——这听起来让人望而生畏。但汤姆，有了 Adobe Express 的直观功能（如模板、生成式人工智能和实时协作），一切都变得前所未有地轻松。Adobe Express。免费试用。在 App Store 中搜索 Adobe Express。
This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. So Tom, we have some incredibly exciting news for our listeners. in Northern Ireland and the Republic of Ireland, don't we?
本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的企业提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。它的人工智能功能可以帮您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理薪资，即便您的企业正面临多方拉扯，也能以合理的价格交付高质量的产品，同时支付给员工与他们价值相符的薪酬，让您的企业在面对纷扰时依然从容不迫。访问 SAP.com 斜杠 uncertainty 了解更多。所以汤姆，我们有一个极其激动人心的消息要告诉身处北爱尔兰和爱尔兰共和国的听众，对吧？
We absolutely do, Dominic, because we are going to be in Belfast, in Dublin and in Cork next year in April, and we will be talking about the tragic story of Titanic. And listeners can buy their tickets by heading to the rest is history.com. So we will be on stage in Belfast at the Waterfront Hall on Friday, 17th of April. We'll be in Dublin at the Convention Centre. on Saturday the 18th of April, and in Cork at the Opera House on Monday, the 20th of April. Tickets are on general sale now at therestishistory.com. So, for your chance to see us on stage live in Belfast, Dublin or Cork,
我们当然有，多米尼克，因为我们明年四月将前往贝尔法斯特、都柏林和科克，我们将会聊聊泰坦尼克号的悲惨故事。听众可以通过访问 therestishistory.com 来购买门票。因此，我们将于4月17日星期五在贝尔法斯特的水滨音乐厅登台演出；4月18日星期六在都柏林的会议中心演出；4月20日星期星期一在科克的歌剧院演出。门票现已在 therestishistory.com 公开发售。因此，想要在贝尔法斯特、都柏林或科克现场观看我们演出的朋友们，
simply head to therestishistory.com to get your tickets. Then I saw the mother of Oedipus, the beautiful epicaste, the enormity she committed. Though she knew not what she did, she married her own son, while he, after slaying his father, married her. But soon enough the gods made it known to the people. Now he, in beautiful Thebes, suffered agonies as he ruled the Cadmians as Lord, all through the gods. God's dire plan, while she went off to the house of Hades, that stern gatekeeper, after hanging a noose straight down from a rafter high in the roof, possessed as she was by her anguish. For him, she left so many woes behind.
只需前往 therestishistory.com 即可购票。接着我看到了俄狄浦斯的母亲，美丽的伊卡斯忒，她犯下了何等滔天的罪行。尽管她不知自己所做为何，却嫁给了自己的亲生儿子，而儿子在杀死父亲后，也娶了她。但很快神明便将此事大白于天下。此后，他在美丽的忒拜饱受折磨，作为领主统治着卡德摩斯人，这一切皆因神明。神明严酷的计划，而她则走向了冥王哈得斯的宅邸，那个严厉的守门人，在一根高高的屋顶横梁上直接垂下一条绞索，吊颈自尽，彼时她已被痛苦彻底吞噬。她为他留下了如此众多的苦难。
So that was Homer in The Odyssey. Translation is by Daniel Mendelsohn, who was in one of our recent Restis History bonus episodes so our club members will know all about him. And Tom, this is the earliest account that we have in Greek literature of how Oedipus, the king of the Cadmains, which means the Thebans, how he slew his own father and married his mother. And she then hanged herself and descended to the house of Hades, which means the underworld. Now, Oedipus, he's not one of the Greek heroes that you read about children's books for obvious reasons. Even so, he is one of the most influential, famous.
以上是荷马在《奥德赛》中的记载。翻译者是丹尼尔·门德尔松，他曾做客我们最近的一期《历史的余烬》加更节目，所以我们的俱乐部成员对他的情况一定了如指掌。汤姆，这是我们在希腊文学中见到的关于卡德摩斯人（即忒拜人）之王俄狄浦斯如何杀死亲父并娶了母亲的最早记载。而她随后便上吊自尽，坠入冥王哈得斯的宅邸，也就是冥界。如今，俄狄浦斯并非你在儿童读物里读到的那种希腊英雄，原因显而易见。即便如此，他依然是整个人类文化中最具影响力、最著名、
celebrated, damned characters in all human culture, because of course he's given his name, among other things, to a very famous complex. And this is partly because the story seems so horrific to us, doesn't it? Kept murdering your father and marrying your mother. It seems to speak to something in the human condition. So unpack it a little bit for us. Well, this notion that the story of Oedipus has a kind of universe. universal resonance that it embodies something about the tragic destiny of the whole of humanity I think is quite widely believed, perhaps in part because of the Oedipus complex, which we will be coming to in due course in this episode. But I think it's also due to the starring role
最受赞誉也备受诅咒的人物之一，因为他当然把自己的名字（除其他事物外）留给了一个非常著名的情结。这部分是因为这个故事在我们看来实在太可怕了，不是吗？居然谋杀了自己的父亲并娶了自己的母亲。它似乎触及了人类境况中的某种东西。所以，给我们稍微剖析一下吧。嗯，这种认为俄狄浦斯的故事具有某种普遍共鸣、体现了全人类悲剧命运的观念，我认为得到了相当广泛的认同，这或许部分是因为俄狄浦斯情结，我们将在本期节目的适当时候谈到它。但我认为这也归功于俄狄浦斯所扮演的主角角色——
that Oedipus has as the hero of the most famous of all Greek tragedies, which was written some three centuries after the age of Homer and Hesiod in Athens. And the life of its author, a man called Sophocles, spanned pretty much the whole of the 5th century BC. And this is really the, when people in their minds eye conjure up an image of the golden age of Greece, This is probably what they see, the Parthenon, Pericles, and so on. But it is also an age that witnesses Athens embroiled in terrible and ultimately disastrous war against its great rival, the city of Sparta. And this play is written against the backdrop of that war. And it massively elaborates on Homer's account, but it also kind of tweaks it.
作为所有希腊悲剧中最著名的一部的主角，该剧创作于雅典的荷马和赫西俄德时代大约三个世纪之后。它的作者索福克勒斯的一生几乎贯穿了整个公元前5世纪。而这正是当人们在脑海中勾勒出希腊黄金时代景象时的真实写照。这大概就是他们所看到的：帕特农神庙、伯里克利等等。但这也是一个见证了雅典被卷入与死敌斯巴达之间可怕且最终灾难性战争的时代。这部戏剧正是在那场战争的背景下创作的。它极大地丰富了荷马的记载，但也对其进行了一些调整。
So when we tend to think of the story of Oedipus, it's the story as told by Sophocles that we think of, I think of. Yeah, not by Homer. Yeah, absolutely. And the story that Edipus tells, I mean, let's give it to people. So as with Homer, so with Sophocles, we are in Thebes, seven gated Thebes, as it's known, from its seven gates. And this is a city 30 miles north of Athens. And it is the dominant power, so the kind of the supreme city in the region of central Greece that is called Biosha. And Thebes is ruled by a king called Laos, and his wife, the queen of Thebes, is called not Epicaste, as in Homer, but according to Sophocles, her name was Jakasta.
因此，当我们倾向于想起俄狄浦斯的故事时，我认为我们想起的是索福克勒斯所讲述的故事。是的，而不是荷马的。是的，完全如此。而俄狄浦斯讲述的故事——我的意思是，让我们把它讲给听众听吧。正如荷马一样，索福克勒斯笔下的我们也身处忒拜，因有七座城门而被称为“七门忒拜”。这是一座位于雅典以北30英里的城市。它是该地区的主导力量，也就是中希腊地区（被称为维奥蒂亚）的至高城市。忒拜由一位名叫拉伊俄斯的国王统治，而他的妻子、忒拜王后不叫荷马笔下的伊卡斯忒，根据索福克勒斯的说法，她的名字叫伊俄卡斯忒。
And Laos and Jakasta have a son, and Laus consults an oracle to find out what the fortune of this is. young boy will be. And the news that comes back isn't brilliant because the oracle reveals, and I quote Sophocles here, that Leus was doomed to perish at the hands of his own child, which isn't at all the kind of prognosis that you want if you're father of a young baby. And so Leus, understandably, wants to try and foil the Oracle. And so he takes the baby from it's caught, and he gets a skewer, and he drives the skewer through the ankles of the baby, and then he hands him over to his wife, Jakasta, and says, get rid of this child. Jakasta, she's obedient to her husband to the degree that she gives the baby over to a household
拉伊俄斯和伊俄卡斯忒生了一个儿子，拉伊俄斯向神谕所请教，以探明这个小男孩的命运将会如何。传回的消息可不算妙，因为神谕揭示道——这里我引用索福克勒斯的话——拉伊俄斯注定要死于自己亲生骨肉之手。如果你是一个刚出生的小宝宝的父亲，这绝对不是你希望听到的预言。因此，拉伊俄斯情理之中地想要设法挫败神谕。于是他把婴儿从摇篮里抱出来，拿了一根尖签，从婴儿的脚踝处刺穿过去，然后把婴儿交给了他的妻子伊俄卡斯忒，说道：“把这个孩子处理掉。”伊俄卡斯忒对丈夫唯命是从，竟然把婴儿交给了家中的一名奴隶，
slave and orders the slave to cast the child away on the trackless mountain. So neither Laos nor Jakaster are ready personally. personally to kill their child, but they're, you know, it's going down the kind of the food chain, down the chain of command. The slave himself can't, he's got this little baby. He can't bring himself to obey his mistress's orders. And so he, he takes the baby up onto the slopes of the nearby mountain, Ketheron, which is a very kind of haunted, kind of sinister place in Greek myth. And there he meets with a shepherd and he hands the baby over. And the shepherd removes the skewer from the baby's ankles.
并命令奴隶将孩子抛弃在荒无人烟的山上。因此，拉伊俄斯和伊俄卡斯忒本人都不愿意亲自动手杀死自己的孩子，但他们把事情推向了食物链的下游，推向了指挥链的下游。奴隶自己也下不了手，他抱着这个小婴儿。他实在狠不下心来违抗女主人的命令。于是他抱着婴儿来到了附近基泰隆山的斜坡上——在希腊神话中，这是一个非常具有鬼魅色彩、有些阴森的地方。他在那里遇到了一位牧羊人，便把婴儿交给了他。牧羊人拔掉了婴儿脚踝上的尖签。
But of course, if you're a baby and you have a skewer driven through your ankles, that gives a lasting injury. And so the baby is given the name by the shepherd of Oedipus, which means in Greek swollen foot. And the shepherd, for a reason that is never explained, we just have to accept on trust that this is what happens, travels with the baby Oedipus to the city of Corinth, which is just beyond the kind of the narrow, Oismos that joins the Peloponnese, the southern part of Greece, to mainland Greece. And in Corinth, there is a king called Polybus and his wife, the queen of Corinth, Maropae, and they are childless, and they are desperate for a son. And the shepherd presents this baby, this foundling, to Polybus and Morope, and they bring Oedipus up as their own child.
但当然，如果你是一个婴儿，脚踝被尖签刺穿，这会留下永久的伤残。于是牧羊人给这个婴儿取名叫俄狄浦斯，在希腊语中意为“肿脚”。出于某种从未得到解释的原因——我们只能选择相信事情就是这样发生 的——牧羊人带着婴儿俄狄浦斯前往科林斯城。科林斯就位于将伯罗奔尼撒（希腊南部）与希腊大陆连接起来的狭窄地峡旁。在科林斯，有一位名叫波吕波斯的国王，他的妻子是科林斯王后墨洛珀，他们膝下无子，极其渴望能有个儿子。牧羊人将这个婴儿、这个弃儿献给了波吕波斯和墨洛珀，他们将俄狄浦斯抚养成人，视如己出。
And Oedipus grows up, never doubting that he is indeed the son of the king and queen of Corinth. Okay. But then there's a twist, isn't that? Because when, by the way, I saw a really weird production of Edipus early this year with Rami Malik as Edipus. Did you see that? Oh, really? Freddy Mercury. Freddy Mercury or the Bond villain in the last No Time to Die. He was much better as Freddy Mercury, I thought. He was a bit of a weird, kind of unsettling, quite slightly stiff Edipus. But Indira Vama played Chakasta, and she was brilliant, I have to say. Anyway, by the bye, Edipus grows up. He's a young man, and he's out messing around in Corinth or whatever, and some drunkard comes up to him and says, you know, you're not really their son, don't you? And Oedipus is shocked by this, and he goes to see them, doesn't he, and says, what's going on? And they're all very upset, and it's all very, you know, it's a real sort of family drama. Well, they deny it
俄狄浦斯一天天长大，从未怀疑过自己确实是科林斯国王和王后的亲生儿子。好吧。但随后出现了一个转折，不是吗？因为——顺便说一句，今年年初我看了部非常诡异的《俄狄浦斯》制作，拉米·马雷克饰演俄狄浦斯。你看过吗？哦，真的吗？弗雷迪·墨星。弗雷迪·墨趣，或者是《无暇赴死》里的邦德反派。我觉得他演弗雷迪·墨趣要好得多。他演的俄狄浦斯有点诡异、让人不安，而且稍微有点僵硬。不过英迪拉·瓦玛饰演伊俄卡斯忒，我得说她太棒了。不管怎样，闲话少叙，俄狄浦斯长大了。他成了一个年轻人，在科林斯四处游荡胡闹什么的，有个醉汉走到他面前对他说：“你知道你其实不是他们的亲生儿子吧？”俄狄浦斯对此感到震惊，于是他去见他们，对吧，问是怎么回事。他们都非常难过，这一切都非常……你知道的，这是一场真正的家庭闹剧。嗯，他们非常愤怒地否认了这一点。
very indignantly. Yeah. Very indignantly. So again, Oedipus still has no reason to doubt that they are truly his parents. But he is upset, and so he does what any hero in such a situation would do. he goes to Delphi to consult the Oracle and he asks Apollo well you know who are my parents I just want to absolutely nail this down but Apollo doesn't answer the question instead what Apollo says is you are doomed to kill your father and to marry your mother no one wants to hear that no and so edipus again to quote Sophocles at this I took to the road putting the stars between me and Corinth determined never to see my home again right so he takes the road that leads from Delphi, and instead of heading southwards to Corinth, he reaches the fork in the road that
非常愤怒地。所以，俄狄浦斯依然没有理由怀疑他们究竟是不是自己的亲生父母。但他心里很难过，于是他做了任何身处这种境地的英雄都会做的事：他前往德尔斐请教神谕，向阿波罗询问：“我的父母究竟是谁？我只想彻底弄清楚这一点。”但阿波罗并没有回答这个问题，相反，阿波罗说的是：“你注定要杀死你的父亲，娶你的母亲。”没有人想听到这个。不。于是俄狄浦斯——再次引用索福克勒斯的话——“听到此话便踏上了旅程，将群星抛在我和科林斯之间，决心再也不回我的家乡。”没错。于是他踏上了从德尔斐出发的道路，却没有向南前往科林斯，而是来到了一条岔路口，
leads northwards towards Thieves. Because he assumes that the prophecy is about his, you know, what we know are his adopted parents. Yes, exactly. And at this fork in the road, he runs into an old man in a chariot who is escorted by a herald, he's got various servants in attendance, and they're coming in the opposite direction from Thieves. And they get into a massive argument about who has the right of way. And the result is the most infamous explosion of road rage in the entire history of world literature. The old man lashes at Oedipus with his whip. Edipus hits the old man with his staff and kills him. He then attacks the old man's servants. He kills them all, or so Oedipus thinks. But in fact, another twist, one of the attendants does escape.
那条路通往北方的忒拜。因为他以为这个预言说的是他的——你知道的——也就是我们所知道的他的养父母。是的，完全正确。就在这个岔路口，他遇到了一位坐在战车里的老者，身边有传令官护卫，还有几个随从侍候，他们正从忒拜的方向迎面驶来。双方为谁拥有路权而爆发了激烈的争吵。结果便是世界文学史上最声名狼藉的一次路怒大爆发。老者用鞭子抽打俄狄浦斯，俄狄浦斯用手杖回击老者并将其杀死。接着他攻击了老者的随从，把他们全杀了，或者说俄狄浦斯以为全杀了。但事实上，又是一个转折，其中一个随从逃脱了。
Listeners should remember this because this is key to what will happen in due course. There is one witness to what happened at this fork in the road. So Oedipus has killed this old man, doesn't know who he is. Listeners can probably guess who he was. Continues on his travels and in due course he approaches seven gated Thebes and the city is in a state of absolute turmoil and it's been hit by twin disasters. And the first of these is that the city's king, Laos, has been murdered, and he was murdered while travelling to Delphi. Wow.
听众们应该记住这一点，因为这是接下来将要发生的事情的关键。有一个人目击了岔路口发生的事。于是俄狄浦斯杀死了这位老者，并不知道他是谁。听众们大概能猜到他是谁。他继续他的旅程，不久之后便接近了七门忒拜，此时这座城市正处于绝对的混乱状态，并遭受了双重灾难的打击。其中第一个灾难是，该市的国王拉伊俄斯被谋杀了，而且他是在前往德尔斐的途中被谋杀的。哇。
Been attacked by Robbers. What a coincidence. Or so it is reported by the only surviving witness to what had happened. The second disaster is the fact that, as tends to happen in Greek myth, a terrifying monster has appeared on the high road that leads into the city. And this is a female monster called the Sphinx. And just to say, in Sophocles' play, in his tragedy, Oedipus, this is only kind of alluded to very elliptically, the Sphinx herself is only mentioned once, and Sophocles is clearly presuming that the people in the audience will know the story of the Sphinx. And this often happens in tragedy. It's assumed by the writers that this is a kind of common stock of stories that people are familiar with. And the story of the Sphinx is basically that she, She is part of these terrible monsters that Hesiod had written about in the Theogony.
被强盗袭击了。多么巧合啊。至少当年见证了事件发生且唯一幸存的目击者是这么报告的。第二个灾难是，正如希腊神话中经常发生的那样，一个可怕的怪物出现在通往城市的高路上。这是一个名为斯芬克斯的雌性怪物。顺便说一句，在索福克勒斯的戏剧、他的悲剧《俄狄浦斯王》中，这一点仅仅被非常含蓄地暗示过，斯芬克斯本人只被提及了一次，索福克勒斯显然假定观众会知道斯芬克斯的故事。这在悲剧中经常发生。作者们默认这是一个人们熟悉的共同故事库。而斯芬克斯的故事基本上是：她，
Hesiod says that she was a sibling of Cerberus, the three-headed dog that guards the underworld, and the Nemean lion, which Heracles had killed. She had come from Ethiopia, sent to Thebes by the goddess Heera. She had the head and breasts of a woman, the body of a lion, the wings of a giant predatory bird. and anyone who walks by the rock on which she is crouched has to answer a riddle. And if they can't answer it, then they will be devoured. And so as she sits on the rock, she is surrounded by the bones and the skulls of the hapless wayfarers who have been unable to answer her riddle.
她是赫西俄德在《神谱》中所描述的那些可怕怪物的同类。赫西俄德说她是刻耳柏洛斯的兄弟姐妹——刻耳柏洛斯是守护冥界的看门三头犬，还有被赫拉克勒斯杀死的涅墨亚狮子。她来自埃塞俄比亚，是女神赫拉派往忒拜的。她有着女人的头颅和胸膛、狮子的身体、巨大猛禽的翅膀。每一个走过她盘踞的岩石的人都必须回答一个谜语。如果他们答不上来，就会被她吞食。因此，当她坐在岩石上时，四周环绕着那些未能解开她谜语的不幸过客的骨骼和头颅。
And the riddle she asks is very famous, so famous that Sophocles doesn't tell us what the riddle is. But we know what it was because it was, again, it was obviously part of the story that everyone knew. And it was written down about 600 years after Sofocles wrote his tragedy in around kind of AD 200 in a sort of posh almanac. And the riddle is, there walks on land a creature of two feet and four feet, which has a single voice. And it also has three feet. Alone of the animals on earth, it changes its nature. Of animals on the earth in the sky and in the sea. When it walks propped on the most feet, then is the speed of its limbs least. And again, in Sophocles' tragedy, we are not told what happens next, but again,
她问的谜语非常著名，以至于索福克勒斯甚至没有告诉我们谜语是什么。但我们知道它是什么，因为——同样地——这显然是每个人都知晓的故事的一部分。大约在索福克勒斯创作悲剧的600年之后，也就是公元200年前后，它被写进了一本高档年鉴里。这个谜语是：大地上走着一个有两只脚和四只脚的生物，它只有一个声音。它也长着三只脚。它是大地上唯一的动物，会改变它的本性。大地上、天空中、大海中的动物。当它靠最多的脚支撑着行走时，它四肢的速度便是最慢的。同样，在索福克勒斯的悲剧里，我们没有被告知接下来发生了什么，但再次从剧中来看，
from hence in the play, it's clearly common knowledge. So, Dominic, the answer to that riddle is? Is it man, Tom? It is. Would you like to explain why it's man? Well, because you have a single voice and you have two feet when you start. No, you have four feet when you start. You're a baby. Yeah, because you're walking on, you have four feet when you start because you're walking on hands and, you know,
这显然是常识。所以，多米尼克，那个谜语的答案是？是人吗，汤姆？正是如此。你愿意解释一下为什么是人吗？嗯，因为你只有一个声音，你一开始有两只脚。不，你一开始有四只脚。你是个婴儿。对，因为你在爬，你一开始有四只脚，因为你用手走路，而且——你知道的，
you're kind of crawling. Then you have two feet, then you have three feet because you have a stick or something of that kind, surely. And then when you're slowest, when you're a baby, yeah, exactly. What an amazing riddle that is.
你有点在爬行。然后你有了两只脚，接着你有了三只脚，因为你拿着拐杖或类似的东西，肯定是的。然后当你最慢的时候，当你还是个婴儿的时候，对，完全正确。多么了不起的一个谜语啊。
It's an amazing riddle. Oedipus, because he's a hero, he susses it, gives the right answer to the Sphinx. The Sphinx is so depressed that her riddle's been answered, that she hurls herself off a cliff, and that's the end of her. And a reward has been kind of proclaimed that anyone who can get rid of the Sphinx will get to marry Laos's widow, Jakasta. And so Edipus has got rid of the Sphinx, and so he duly marries Jocasta, and he rules in Laus' place as kind of the king, kind of the king,
这真是个了不起的谜语。俄狄浦斯因为是个英雄，他猜透了，给出了斯芬克斯正确的答案。斯芬克斯因为自己的谜语被解开而沮丧至极，以至于从悬崖上纵身跃下，她的故事就这样结束了。忒拜曾宣告过悬赏：任何能除掉斯芬克斯的人将得以迎娶拉伊俄斯的遗孀伊俄卡斯忒。于是俄狄浦斯除掉了斯芬克斯，便顺理成章地娶了伊俄卡斯忒，并在拉伊俄斯的位置上作为国王统治，就像个国王一样——
but will come to exactly what his status is in due course. I'll tell you what's very unfortunate for Oedipus is that he clearly doesn't resemble either Laos or Jakasta because it doesn't occur to anybody, but they might be in any way related. But why would they? They might look similar. Yeah, well, kind of particularly long chin or something.
但我们稍后会谈到他确切的身份地位。我告诉你对俄狄浦斯来说非常不幸的是，他显然既不像拉伊俄斯也不像伊俄卡斯忒，因为没有人想过他们可能有什么亲缘关系。但他们为什么会这么想呢？他们可能会长得像。对，比如有特别突出的下巴什么的。
Yeah, like a Habsburg inheritance or something. Yeah, maybe. Anyway, I think that the plot of this is something you don't want to look at too closely. It progresses with a terrible inexorability, if you don't look too closely at the joins. So, Oedipus has become king, and he rules very, very well, and the people of Thebes are very grateful to him, not just because he's got rid of the Sphinx, but also because he's a just ruler.
是的，就像哈布斯堡王朝的遗传特征之类的。对，也许吧。无论如何，我认为这个情节的剧情是不经推敲的。如果你不仔细去审视那些衔接处的话，它便以一种可怕的不可阻挡之势推进着。于是，俄狄浦斯成了国王，他统治得非常非常好，忒拜人民对他感激涕零，不仅因为他除掉了斯芬克斯，还因为他是一位公正的统治者。
He wins the loyalty of the foremost men of Thebes, which includes Jacaster's brother, Crayon, the city's elders, they salute him as the first of men, whether in the daily affairs of mortal life or in the dealings of mortals with the more than mortal. He and Jakarta has to have a very happy marriage. They have four children, so two sons, Etiocles and Polyneses, and two daughters, Antigone and Ismane. And everything seems to be going brilliantly. But then Dominic, disaster in the form of a terrible plague, which sweeps Thieves. And it's evident that this can only mean that the gods are angry with Thebes, with someone in Thebes, perhaps, that some terrible crime has been committed. This is where the play starts, isn't it? And the rest is flashbacks. It begins. So Oedipus
他赢得了忒拜显贵们的忠诚，其中包含伊俄卡斯忒的兄弟克瑞翁以及城中的长老们，他们向他致敬，称他为人类当中的第一人，无论是在世俗日常生活的事务中，还是在凡人与超凡神明打交道时。他和伊俄卡斯忒拥有着非常幸福的婚姻。他们育有四个孩子：两个儿子——厄特克洛斯和波吕涅克斯，两个女儿——安提戈涅和伊斯墨涅。一切似乎都进展得极为顺利。然而多米尼克，灾难降临了，一场可怕的瘟疫席卷了忒拜。显然，这只能意味着神明对忒拜感到愤怒，或许是对忒拜的某个人感到愤怒，犯下了某桩可怕的罪行。戏剧就是从这里开始的，对吧？其余的都是闪回。它开始了。于是俄狄浦斯
sends his brother-in-law Crayon to Delphi to try and find out why the gods are angry. And Crayon returns with the report of what is wrong. And this is where the play starts. So Crayon's report of what Apollo has revealed is that Thebes is polluted by the murderer of King Leus, who had never been caught. And specifically Apollo has declared, this unclean creature, the murderer, must be driven into exile before he destroys us all. And so Oedipus says, fine. It is my duty as king to play the detective and to track down Leus's murderer. So as well as being a tragedy, Sophocles' play is also the first great detective story. and that's a huge part of what makes it so gripping.
派遣他的小舅子克瑞翁前往德尔斐，试图查明神明为何发怒。克瑞翁带着关于问题所在的报告回来了。戏剧正是从这里开场。因此，克瑞翁带回的阿波罗神谕揭示的内容是：忒拜因国王拉伊俄斯的谋杀者而受到玷污，此人从未被抓获。阿波罗明确宣布：这个不洁的生物，也就是凶手，必须被驱逐流放，在他在毁灭我们所有人之前。于是俄狄浦斯说：“很好。作为国王，我的职责就是扮演侦探，追查拉伊俄斯的凶手。”因此，索福克勒斯的剧作不仅是一部悲剧，也是第一部伟大的侦探小说，这正是它如此引人入胜的巨大原因。
So how is you going to investigate what's been going on? Well, there is a top intelligence source in Thieves. And this is a man, although he hasn't always been a man, called Terracius. And Terracius had a very, very eventful life. So as a young man, he'd been strolling in the Enviroix beyond Thieves, and he'd come across two copulating snakes and he'd hit them with his staff. Unfortunately, these snakes turn out to have been sacred
那么，他将如何调查所发生的事情呢？嗯，忒拜有一个顶级情报消息源。这个人名叫忒瑞西阿斯，虽然他并非一直是个男人。忒瑞西阿斯度过了非常非常坎坷的一生。年轻时，他在忒拜郊外的野外漫步，偶然遇到了两条正在交配的蛇，便用手杖击打它们。不幸的是，这两条蛇原来是神后赫拉的神圣之物，
to here are the queen of the gods and so she punishes him and I'm using the word there that the Greeks would have used by turning him into a woman for seven years so for seven years he lives as a woman and then he gets turned back into a man. So that's very contemporary, isn't it? But at the end of these seven years
于是她惩罚了他——我这里使用的是希腊人会用的那个词——将他变成了一个女人，持续了七年。因此，他以女人的身份生活了七年，随后又被变回了男人。这非常具有当代色彩，不是吗？但在经历了这七年之后，
he now has the opportunity you to solve a question that I think is playing on, you know, has often played on people's minds. So, Hera and Zeus have been having one of their domestics, one of their rows, and the argument is about whether men or women enjoy sex more. And Hira says, well, obviously, men enjoy it more. And Zeus says, no, no, the ladies enjoy it more. They get, they get all the place. He's speaking from experience.
他现在有机会去解决一个我认为一直盘旋在人们心头、常常萦绕在人们脑海中的问题。事情是这样的：赫拉和宙斯一直在进行家庭琐事般的争吵，他们争论的焦点是男人还是女人更能享受性爱的乐趣。赫拉说：“很显然，男人更享受它。”而宙斯则说：“不，不，女士们更享受它。她们能得到所有的快感。”他是凭经验在说话。
Sirius uniquely can pronounce on this. And he says, the ladies do enjoy it more, you know. And Hira doesn't want to hear this at all, does she? She's outraged by this. And she now punishes him again. Oh, my God. By striking him blind. Yeah.
只有宙斯能够对此做出权威的裁决。而他说：“女士们确实更享受它，你知道的。”赫拉根本不想听到这话，不是吗？她对此感到大发雷霆。于是她再次惩罚了他。哦，天哪！将其双目失明。是的。
Yeah. So he's having a very bad deal from Hera. But Zeus compensates him by making him, giving his a profit. He can see into the, you know, he's got second side to whatever. Yes, exactly. You can see into the future and all kinds of things that he understands things that most mortals don't. So he seems ideal to solve the crime.
是的。所以他从赫拉那里得到了非常糟糕的下场。但宙斯补偿了他，让他成为了一个先知。他能看穿——你知道的——他拥有了某种“第二视觉”之类的能力。是的，完全正确。你可以看透未来以及各种事情，他能理解绝大多数凡人无法理解的事情。所以他似乎是解决这桩罪行的理想人选。
And so this is why Oedipus sense for him. And Oedipus says, okay, Theracius, you know, you're so smart. You know things that are hidden from the rest of us. Who is the murderer? And Terracius, for understandable reasons, refuses to answer. Oedipus loses his temper and says, well, the only reason you're not telling me must be because you are complicit in the murder. To which Teraceus responds in one of the most chilling lines in the whole of drama, you yourself are the killer you seek.
这也是为什么俄狄浦斯派人去请他。俄狄浦斯说：“好吧，忒瑞西阿斯，你知道的，你这么聪明。你知道我们其他人所不知道的秘密。凶手是谁？”而忒瑞西阿斯出于可以理解的原因，拒绝回答。俄狄浦斯勃然大怒，说道：“好吧，你没有告诉我实情的唯一原因，一定是因为你同谋了这场谋杀。”对此，忒瑞西阿斯做出了全剧中最令人毛骨悚然的台词之一的回应：“你自己就是你要找的凶手。”
And Oedipus doesn't understand what he's saying. And Theracius then says that, you know, blind though I am, you are blinder still. And in that there is a kind of ominous portending of what is to come. Yeah. So Oedipus is furious. Jakasta, his wife, tries to calm him down. And she does this by saying, look, you can't. rely on prophets. You know, sometimes they get things wrong. And as an example of this, she cites
俄狄浦斯根本听不懂他在说什么。接着忒瑞西阿斯说：“虽然我瞎了，但你比我还要瞎。”这句话中有一种对未来的不祥预兆。是的。因此俄狄浦斯狂怒不已。他的妻子伊俄卡斯忒试图让他冷静下来。她通过这样的话来做到这一点：“听着，你不能依赖预言家。你知道，有时候他们会弄错。”作为例子，她列举了
the prophecy that she and Laos have been given and which she says obviously hadn't come true. You know, Laus was told that he would be killed by his son, but he wasn't killed by his son. He was killed by bandits at a fork in the road. And at the mention of the fork in the road, Edithus does a double take. So presumably, this has never been mentioned before to Oedipus. It's the first. It's the first he's heard of it. And so he then asked Jakasta to describe Laos, which Jakasta does. And her description of her dead husband throws Edipus into a massive panic. And when he's told that actually a witness to the attack had survived and that this is how the news had come back, he orders this witness to be sent for. And Oedipus then tells Jakaster about his road rage incident at the T-junction,
她和拉伊俄斯曾得到的那个预言，并称那个预言显然没有成真。你知道，拉伊俄斯曾被告知他会死于儿子之手，但他并不是死于儿子之手，而是死于岔路口上的强盗。一提到岔路口，俄狄浦斯猛然一惊。据推测，这件事以前从未向俄狄浦斯提起过。这是他第一次听说。于是他让伊俄卡斯忒描述拉伊俄斯的模样，伊俄卡斯忒照做了。她对死去的丈夫的描述让俄狄浦斯陷入了极度恐慌。当被告知袭击事件其实有一名目击者幸存、消息正是由此传回时，他下令将这名目击者传唤来。接着俄狄浦斯向伊俄卡斯忒讲述了自己在三岔路口的路怒事件：
the old man, the chariot, all of that. And Jakasta turns completely white and looks at him in absolute horror. Just to say, if you ever get a chance to see Edipus to the listeners, this scene is absolutely, I mean, it is absolutely hypnotic. This sort of sense of dread as the two of them start to realize what, you know, the reality of their relationship. I mean, if it's done, if it's a good production, it is a brilliant and brilliant scene. It's like a kind of, um, a machine.
老者、战车，所有这些。而伊俄卡斯忒面色惨白，以绝对惊恐的眼神看着他。顺便说一句，如果听众们有机会去看《俄狄浦斯王》，这一幕绝对——我是说——绝对具有催眠般的魔力。当他们两人开始意识到——你知道的——他们关系的现实时，那种恐惧感。我是说，如果制作精良的话，这是一个绝妙无比的场面。它就像一台严密的酷刑机器，越压越紧，把受害者越勒越紧。太可怕了。所以他们两人都处于即将理解所发生事情的边缘。紧接着，又一个转折发生了。
machine of torture pressing in closer and closer and getting the victim tighter and tighter in its coils. It's terrifying. So both of them are kind of on the cusp of arriving at an understanding of what has happened. And then there is another twist. A messenger arrives from Corinth with news that Polybus, the man the king, who Oedipus believes is his father, has died. And to everyone's surprise, Oedipus isn't upset about this at all. He's delighted. And when people say, well, you know, what's going on? Why are you delighted that your father's died? He explains about the prophecy he'd had from Delphi and says, well, now at least I don't have to worry about killing my father. There is, though, still the possibility that he might, as if the prophecy is true, end up
一个信使从科林斯赶来，带来了一个消息：俄狄浦斯以为是自己父亲的那个男人、科林斯国王波吕波斯去世了。令所有人惊讶的是，俄狄浦斯对此一点也不难过。他欣喜若狂。当人们问：“好吧，你知道的，怎么回事？为什么你父亲死了你还这么高兴？”他解释了自己从德尔斐得到的预言，并说道：“好吧，现在至少我不用担心杀害我的父亲了。”然而，仍然存在这样一种可能性：如果预言是真的，他最终可能会
sleeping with Morope, the queen of Corinth, who he thinks is his mother. But the messenger then says, oh, you don't need to worry about that. It's fine. Marope, the Queen of Corinth. She's not your mother. And Edipus again goes completely pale and says, well, you know, what do you mean? How do you know this? And the messenger reveals that he is the very same shepherd who'd been given the infant Oedipus on the slopes of Mount Ketheron by Jacaster's slave and had then given the baby to Polybus and Maropae to be fostered by them. What are the chances? Yeah, massive chance. Yeah. And now that the twists and the coincidences are coming. fast and furious, because when the man that Oedipus had sent for, the guy who had, you know, the sole survivor of the road raid incident at the fork in the road, when he turns up, he turns out to be Jakasta's slave, the man who'd been given, you know, the baby boy with the skewer through his ankles to take up onto Mount Kitheron. And again, people may think,
与科林斯王后墨洛珀同床共枕，而他一直以为墨洛珀是他的母亲。但信使随后说道：“哦，你不需要担心这个。没事的。科林斯王后墨洛珀。她不是你的母亲。”俄狄浦斯再次面色惨白，说道：“好吧，你知道的，这是什么意思？你怎么知道的？”信使透露，他正是当年在基泰隆山坡上从伊俄卡斯忒的奴隶手中接过婴儿俄狄浦斯，然后把婴儿交给波吕波斯和墨洛珀抚养的那位牧羊人。这几率得有多大？是的，几率太大了。是的。而现在，各种转折和巧合接踵而至，铺天盖地。因为当俄狄浦斯派人去找的那个人——也就是岔路口路怒事件中唯一的幸存者——出现时，他竟然就是伊俄卡斯忒的奴隶，就是那个曾接过带有脚踝穿刺伤口的男婴并将其带到基泰隆山的人。再次地，人们可能会想，
well, this is a bit much of, you know, a bit too much of a coincidence. Actually, this is less of a coincidence. It's pointed out by Edith Hall in a brilliant essay that as a slave, the man would have been constantly in attendance on his royal owners. So it's perfectly plausible, if I could use that word in connection with this story, that he would have, you know, if he's a trusted slave, he would have been given the task of disposing of the baby and he would have been on attendance on Laos as he's traveling to Delphi. So that bit perhaps, you know, more credible. Edipus is saying to this slave, you know, tell me what happened. And like Theracius, the slave doesn't want to talk.
这未免有点太巧合了。实际上，这并不算太巧合。埃迪丝·霍尔在一篇精彩的文章中指出，作为一名奴隶，这个人会一直服侍他的皇室主人。所以——如果我能在与这个故事相关的语境下使用这个词的话——这是完全合理的，如果他是一个受信任的奴隶，他会被赋予处理掉婴儿的任务，而且当拉伊俄斯前往德尔斐时，他也一定会随行伺候。所以那一部分或许更加可信。俄狄浦斯对这个奴隶说：“告诉我发生了什么。”和忒瑞西阿斯一样，奴隶不想开口。
You know, he can't bring himself to reveal it. Oedipus then threatens him with torture. And at this point, the truth comes out. And the slave reveals that he'd been given this baby by Jakasta. So this is the point when there's no escaping the reality. An agnoresis, the Greeks called it. It's the kind of the moment of recognition. The old man, Oedipus is slain at the fork in the road, was laid.
他狠不下心来揭露真相。于是俄狄浦斯威胁要对其实施酷刑。就在这时，真相大白了。奴隶坦白了这个婴儿是伊俄卡斯忒交给他。所以，这就是再也无法逃避现实的时刻。希腊人称之为“认出”（Anagnorisis）。这是某种认知时刻。俄狄浦斯在岔路口杀害的老人，正是拉伊俄斯；
Eidipus, his own father, Jakasta, his queen, the mother of his four children, is his own mother. And as in the camp that you opened with from Homer in the Odyssey, so in Sophocles, Jakasta hangs herself. And Edipus, and this is a detail that's not in Homer, goes to see the hanging body of his wife-stroke mother, and she's wearing two golden brooches that are kind of pinning up her dress, and he removes these brooches and he stabs the points into his eyes and so that's where the no terracius had warned him you are blinder than i am idipus is now literally blind and crayon his brother-in-law stroke uncle
俄狄浦斯自己的父亲；伊俄卡斯忒，他的王后、他四个孩子的母亲，正是他的亲生母亲。正如你在开头引用的荷马《奥德赛》中的选段一样，在索福克勒斯的剧中，伊俄卡斯忒也上吊自杀了。而俄狄浦斯——这是荷马笔下没有的细节——前去看望妻子兼母亲悬挂的尸体，她身上佩戴着两枚别着裙装的金饰针，他取下这些饰针，将尖端狠狠刺入自己的双眼。于是，正如忒瑞西阿斯之前警告过他的那样：“你比我还要瞎。”俄狄浦斯现在真的瞎了。克瑞翁，他的小舅子兼舅舅，
tells edipus your reign is over i am now going to rule in thieves and the play ends with so every tragedy has a chorus and the chorus at the end of edipus's tragedy laments the horror of what has happened. None can truly be called happy, they say, until that day when he bears his happiness down to the grave in peace. And I noticed in your notes you talk about, you know, not just that it's an emotionally kind of devastating story,
对俄狄浦斯说：“你的统治结束了。我现在要统治忒拜了。”戏剧在合唱中落幕——每一部悲剧都有合唱队——俄狄浦斯悲剧结尾处的合唱队哀叹着所发生事情的恐怖。他们说，没有人能真正被称为幸福，直到那个人平安地将他的幸福带入坟墓的那一天。我注意到在你的笔记中，你谈到了——不仅是它是一个情感上极具毁灭性的故事，
but you talk about how taught and compressed it is. And that's actually the thing that really struck me about it seen the recent production. I think it was the old Vic. This sort of sense of claustrophobia. It's one of these classic examples of, a play that is set in a, over a very short space of time, because it's just a series of conversations, it's in the same place, a very small group of characters, and you just have
而且你谈到了它的紧凑和凝练。这其实是观看最近那场制作时真正震撼到我的地方。我想那是老维克剧院的演出。那种幽闭恐惧症的感觉。这是一部经典的戏剧范例，设定在一个非常短的时间跨度内，因为它只是一系列对话，发生在同一个地点，由一小群角色演绎，而你从一开始就能感觉到
this sense from the very outset of the walls beginning to close in. There's no escape from it. There's an intensity to it, and a sort of a terrifying kind of hypnotic quality to what unfolds. Yeah, and it was these qualities that led Aristotle, the great philosopher, who wrote a lost book about comedy, which Umberto Echo fans will recognize that. It's in the name of the rose. But also a famous work on tragedy. And he praised Oedipus as being the greatest of all tragedies and providing the model of what a tragedy should be. And in the 16th century, Renaissance theorists kind of summed up what Aristotle admired about Oedipus as the three unities. So unity of place, it's in the, you know, one location, unity of time. So you're not
四周的墙壁开始合拢。无处可逃。其中有一种张力，以及对剧情发展的一种令人毛骨悚然的、催眠般的特质。是的，正是这些特质促使伟大的哲学家亚里士多德——他曾写过一本关于喜剧的失传著作，温贝托·埃科的粉丝们会认出这一点，它就在《玫瑰的名字》里，但也有一部关于悲剧的著名著作——他称赞俄狄浦斯是所有悲剧中最伟大的，并提供了悲剧应有的典范。在16世纪，文艺复兴时期的理论家们将亚里士多德对俄狄浦斯推崇备至的特点总结为了“三一律”。即地点统一，它发生在——你知道的——单一地点；时间统一，所以你不是
jumping around all over the place. The plot of Oedipus is compressed within, you know, what you see is what you get. And unity of action, i.e. there shouldn't be loads of kind of mad subplots taking you off. Yeah. So it's the model of a tragedy, but it is, you know, as we said, it's the first great detective story and the twist, you know, it's worthy of Agatha Christie. the detective investigating a crime who discovers that he himself is the criminal. And the mad thing is that these tragedies were staged as part of a competition. Sophocally's only one second prize. Imagine how good that top play must have been.
到处乱跳。《俄狄浦斯王》的情节被压缩在——你知道的——所见即所得的范围内；动作统一，即不应该有大量疯狂的支线情节把你带偏。是的。所以它是悲剧的典范，但它——正如我们所说——是第一部伟大的侦探小说，而且其转折——它配得上阿加莎·克里斯蒂。侦探调查一起犯罪，却发现自己正是罪犯。疯狂的是，这些悲剧是在一场比赛中上演的。索福克勒斯竟然只得了第二名。想象一下当时的头名作品得有多优秀啊。
It might have been brilliant. It didn't survive. And I would say that the classes today agree with Aristotle that it's number one. So again, to quote Edith Hall, who is an excellent critic, Dominique. She once complimented you on something. Possibly. Oh, come on. That's, yeah.
它可能真的很棒。不过它并没有流传下来。我想说今天的古典学者们赞同亚里士多德的看法，认为它就是第一名。所以，再次引用埃迪丝·霍尔的话，她是一位出色的评论家，多米尼克。她曾经在某事上称赞过你。可能吧。哦，得了吧。那确实是——是的。
She described Sophocles as this definitive tragedy. Well, people can, I mean, people can discount that if she's been dissing out praise to lesser authors. Anyway, it is a great tragedy. She may have mentioned that my translation for Rodgers was excellent. Oh, come on. I can't believe you. You said that explicitly. You hinted at it, and then that wasn't enough for you.
她将索福克勒斯描述为这部决定性的悲剧。好吧，人们可以——我是说——如果她一直在向较逊色的作家抛出赞美之词的话，人们是可以对那话打折扣的。无论如何，这是一部伟大的悲剧。她可能提到过我为罗杰斯翻译的作品非常出色。哦，得了吧。我真不敢相信你。你明明是暗示了这一点，然后这还不能满足你。
And you want, I mean, why don't you just read it out? Why don't you read out the review? Well, it's in the spirit of Oedipus. It's the bombshell revelation. People often let themselves down in this podcast, but nobody's let themselves down as badly as you out there. Right, on that bombshell, we will explore what it all means, because Sopholkis, of course, is not the only writer to have talked about Edipus.
你还想——我是说——你为什么不直接读出来呢？你为什么不把那篇评论读出来呢？好吧，这很符合俄狄浦斯的精神。这就是重磅炸弹般的爆料。人们经常在这档播客里让自己失望，但没有人像你们这些听众那样让自己失望得这么彻底。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们将探讨这一切意味着什么，因为索福克勒斯当然不是唯一一个谈论过俄狄浦斯的作家。
The most famous writer, probably even more famous than Sophocles, Tom, because I guess a lot of people today are not experts in Greek tragedy. You don't know about Sophocles. The most famous writer was a psychoanalyst from Vienna. And after the break, we'll be exploring what that gentleman had to say. Come back after the break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most?
最著名的作家，可能甚至比索福克勒斯还要出名，汤姆——因为我猜现在很多人并不是希腊悲剧专家，你们不知道索福克勒斯——最著名的作家是一位来自维也纳的精神分析学家。中场休息过后，我们将探讨这位先生有何高见。休息之后，马上回来。本期节目由 Uber 赞助播出。现在，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候出现的那种感觉吗？
We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. During the Volvo Fall Experience event, discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute.
我们有时都需要那种时刻，而 Uber 深知这一点。Uber 不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖，它代表着无论如何都会出现。就像为你远方的朋友在他们生病时送去热汤，在他们低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么事，你都会出现。只要有心，我们就在路上。Uber，在路上。立即下载该应用程序。在沃尔沃金秋体验活动期间，探索非凡的优惠和充满巧思的设计，为您的金秋冒险留出充足的空间。亲身体验沃尔沃传奇般的安全性如何为每一个清爽的早晨通勤带来内心的平静。
This September, Lisa 2026 XE90 plug-in hybrid from $599 bi-weekly at 3.99% during the Volvo Fall Experience event. Conditions supply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to explorevolvo.com. Reading, playing, learning.
今年九月，在沃尔沃金秋体验活动期间，租赁 2026 款 XC90 插电式混合动力车，每两周 599 美元起，利率低至 3.99%。须受条件限制，请访问您当地的沃尔沃零售商或访问 explorevolvo.com。阅读、游戏、学习。
Stellist lenses do more than just correct your child's vision. They slow down the progression of myopia. So your child can continue to discover all the world has to offer through their own eyes. Light the path to a brighter future with stellar lenses for myopia control. Learn more at SLR.com and ask your family eye care professional for SLR Stellist Lenses at your child's next visit.
星乐斯镜片不仅仅能矫正您孩子的视力。它们还能减缓近视的发展。这样您的孩子就能通过自己的双眼继续探索这个世界所能提供的一切。用星乐斯近视管理镜片点亮通往更光明未来的道路。访问 SLR.com 了解更多信息，并在您孩子下次访问时向您的家庭眼科专家咨询 SLR 星乐斯镜片。
As with my patients, so with myself, I have identified love of the mother and jealousy of the father. and I believe it now to be a general phenomenon of early childhood. So that was Sigmund Freud writing on the 15th of October 1897, and at that point he had been working for two years on his most groundbreaking book, which was called The Interpretation of Dreams. And Freud was pondering the mysteries of the subconscious. He believed that people had in the attic, in the cupboard, all kinds of unacknowledged fears and anxieties and desires, including sexual desires,
正如对待我的病人一样，对于我自己，我也发现了对母亲的爱和对父亲的嫉妒，我如今相信这是早期童年普遍存在的现象。这是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德在1897年10月15日写下的，当时他已经为他最具开创性的著作——名为《梦的解析》——工作了两年。弗洛伊德当时正在沉思潜意识的奥秘。他相信人们的阁楼里、碗橱里，都藏着各种未经承认的恐惧、焦虑和欲望，包括性欲，
and Freud had come to believe that in the story of Oedipus, he had found a key to unlocking some of the darkest secrets of the human mind. Two years later, when he published the interpretation of dreams, Oedipus's story featured very prominently in it, didn't it, Tom? It did. So to quote him, Edipus's destiny moves us only because it might have been ours. Because the oracle lays the same curse upon us before our birth as upon him.
弗洛伊德开始相信，他在俄狄浦斯的故事中找到了一把钥匙，可以解开人类心灵中最黑暗的一些秘密。两年后，当他出版《梦的解析》时，俄狄浦斯的故事在其中占据了非常显赫的位置，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。引用他的话来说，俄狄浦斯的命运之所以能打动我们，仅仅是因为它本可能是我们的命运。因为神谕在我们出生之前就给我们降下了与他相同的诅咒。
It is the fate of all of us, perhaps, to direct our first sexual impulse towards our mother and our first hatred and our first murderous fish against our father. Our dreams convince us that this is so. Now personally, I feel the word perhaps in that is quite a lot of heavy lifting. But this was not the opinion of Freud's admirers. So on his 50th birthday, which was the 6th of May 1906, his fans presented him with this kind of medallion. And on one side, there was an image of Freud in profile. And on the other, there was an image of Oedipus with the Sphinx.
也许我们所有人的命运，都是将我们最初的性冲动指向母亲，将我们最初的仇恨和最初的弑亲冲动指向父亲。我们的梦境让我们确信事实确实如此。现在就我个人而言，我觉得这句话里的“也许”承载了相当多沉重的含义。但这并不是弗洛伊德崇拜者们的看法。因此，在他50岁生日那天，也就是1906年5月6日，他的崇拜者们送给他这样一块奖章。奖章的一面是弗洛伊德的侧面像，另一面则是俄狄浦斯与斯芬克斯的形象。
That's such a strange present to receive, isn't it? No, not if you're Freud. Because beneath Oedipus, they had put a quotation from Sophocles' play. He who knew the famed riddle and was a man most mighty. So aligning Oedipus with Freud. And in 1910, Freud coined the most famous phrase in the whole of psychoanalysis. I mean, one of the most famous phrases to have been, to have emerged from the 20th century, the Oedipus complex. And, you know, it remains part of pop culture to this day, all this kind of, tell me about your mother kind of stuff.
收到这样的礼物真是太奇怪了，不是吗？不，如果你是弗洛伊德的话就不奇怪了。因为在俄狄浦斯下方，他们刻上了索福克勒斯戏剧中的一句台词：“他知晓著名的谜语，曾是权倾一世之人。”以此将俄狄浦斯与弗洛伊德联系起来。1910年，弗洛伊德创造了整个精神分析学中最著名的短语。我的意思是，它是20世纪涌现出的最著名的短语之一——俄狄浦斯情结。而且，你知道的，直到今天它依然是流行文化的一部分，比如所有这种“跟我聊聊你母亲”之类的内容。
So that takes us to the question about this. of Edibus, is it specific? Is it distinctively Greek? Does it come from a particular historical time and place? Or, as Freud believed, is it expressing something universal about the human condition? So in other words, something that was as true in Vienna in the 1890s as it was in classical Athens. And most people, I think, take the attitude, don't they, that myths are timeless. But they express something that is, you know, it looks. different at different time periods, but it's always there. And the Oedipus complex will always be with us because it's part of being human. But I'm going to guess that you don't think that.
这就把我们引向了关于俄狄浦斯的这个问题：它是特殊的吗？它具有独特的希腊特色吗？它源于某个特定的历史时空吗？还是像弗洛伊德所相信的那样，它表达了关于人类境况的某种普遍的东西？换句话说，它在1890年代的维也纳和在古典时期的雅典一样真实。我想，大多数人都认为神话是永恒的。它们表达了这样一种东西，你知道的，它在不同的历史时期看起来有所不同，但它始终存在。俄狄浦斯情结将永远伴随着我们，因为它是人性的一部分。但我猜你并不这么认为。
Well, I mean, just to say that that assumption on Freud's part, that it embodies timeless truths about the nature of the human subconscious, is part of a much broader trend in Western culture, really reaching back to the romantic period, that, as you say, that myth embodies kind of timeless truths. If you can only fathom what they mean, you will crack the riddle of what it is to be human. And it's something that you see. I mean, you said in romanticism, but also, say, in existentialism. So, Camus was all over it. Camus or T.S. Eliot, modernism, you know, that myths are still with us in different forms. And it appeals to people across the political spectrum. So the Nazis, they were all into that idea, but so have kind of new age, you know, all that kind of stuff.
嗯，我的意思是，仅仅指出弗洛伊德的那个假设——即它体现了关于人类潜意识本质的永恒真理——其实是西方文化中一个更广泛趋势的一部分，这个趋势实际上可以追溯到浪漫主义时期。正如你所说，神话体现了某种永恒的真理。如果你能弄懂它们的含义，你就能破解人性的谜题。这种现象随处可见。我是说，你提到了浪漫主义，但也体现在存在主义中，比如加缪就对它深信不疑。加缪或T.S.艾略特、现代主义，你知道的，神话以不同的形式依然伴随着我们。它吸引着整个政治谱系的人。所以纳粹对这个想法非常热衷，新时代运动之类的内容也同样如此。
So it's a very kind of fundamental conviction. As you say, I do not think that myth is timeless. And even if its power can transcend history, because there's no question that to sit down and watch Sophocles, if you get a good production, as you did, I mean, it is incredibly powerful still. But the tragedy itself emerges from very precise and distinctive historical contexts. And I think that the story of Oedipus is a perfect illustration of this, because Sofekle's, when he wrote it, was not, I don't think he was channeling the secret impulses of his subconscious at all. You know, that play could not have been written in Fantasy Ecna Vienna.
所以这是一种非常根本的信念。正如你所说，我不认为神话是永恒的。即使它的力量能够超越历史——因为毫无疑问，如果你能看到一场精彩的索福克勒斯戏剧演出，正如你所经历的那样，你会发现它依然具有不可思议的强大力量。但悲剧本身是从非常精确且独特的历史背景中诞生的。我认为俄狄浦斯的故事就是一个完美的例证，因为索福克勒斯在写作时，我一点也不认为他在宣泄自己潜意识中的秘密冲动。你知道，那部剧根本不可能在虚构的维也纳被写出来。
It could only have been written in the democracy of fifth century Athens. And we'll come to that in a moment how Sophocles tragedy is a play at least as much about Athens as it is about Thieves. But before we do that, just to dwell on one key thing about that explains the myth of Oedipus. Although Sophocles' tragedy, as we've been saying, it's very tight, very claustrophobic, it absolutely does not exist in isolation. Edipus is just a single character in the great sweep of a famous epic. So in our previous episode, we talked about how Zeus had sponsored two terrible wars, which had the aim of wiping out the race of the heroes.
它只能在公元前五世纪的雅典民主制中被孕育出来。我们一会儿就会谈到索福克勒斯的悲剧是如何在很大程度上展现雅典，就像它展现底比斯一样。但在我们讨论那个之前，先来探讨一下解释俄狄浦斯神话的一个关键点。尽管索福克勒斯的悲剧，正如我们一直所说的那样，结构非常紧凑、充满压抑感，但它绝对不是孤立存在的。俄狄浦斯只是宏大史诗巨作中的一个单一角色。所以在我们上一集中，我们谈到了宙斯如何资助了两场可怕的战争，其目的是消灭英雄这一种族，
and how the Trojan War was one of these, but the other was an earlier conflict, and we quoted Hesiod, the war before seven gated Thebes as rivals fought over the flocks of Oedipus. But this is a four-generational death struggle, and it begins, as myths in Greece, tend to begin with a rape,
特洛伊战争是其中之一，但另一场则是更早的冲突，我们引用了赫西奥德的话：“在七门底比斯之前，当竞争对手为俄狄浦斯的羊群而战时爆发的战争。”但这其实是一场跨越四代人的生死之争，它和希腊神话一样，往往以一场强暴拉开帷幕，
with the abduction by Zeus of a Phoenician princess called Europa. And Zeus notoriously disguises himself as a bull appears on the beach outside the city of Tyre and Europa is a princess from Tyre and she clambers on on the bull's back and the bull then plunges into the sea and swims away to Crete and there Europa stays and she gives birth to three sons and the most famous of these is Minos as in the story of the Minotaur and the labyrinth and deedleus and all of that. Europa has a brother called Cadmus, the Prince of Tyre, and Cadmus is sent by their father to go and search for Europa, and he travels to Greece and he comes to Delphi and he asks for help, and Apollo says, you're never going to find her. Give up your quest. Instead, what you should do is to go and find a cow that has a half moon on the flank. And then Apollo says, you were to found a city where this heifer, by divine inspiration, falls to the ground, stretching out her way.
宙斯绑架了一位名叫欧罗巴的腓尼基公主。众所周知，宙斯把自己伪装成一头公牛，出现在泰尔市外的海滩上。欧罗巴是泰尔的一位公主，她爬上了公牛的背，公牛随后冲入大海，游向克里特岛。欧罗巴留在了那里，生下了三个儿子，其中最著名的是米诺斯，也就是米诺斯牛、迷宫和代达罗斯等故事中的那个米诺斯。欧罗巴有一个兄弟叫卡德穆斯，是泰尔的王子。卡德穆斯被他们的父亲派去寻找欧罗巴，他一路旅行来到希腊，来到德尔斐请求帮助。阿波罗说：“你永远找不到她了。放弃你的搜寻吧。相反，你应该去做的是去寻找一头肋部带有半月形斑纹的母牛。”接着阿波罗说：“当这头母牛在神圣的灵感驱使下倒地，伸出疲惫的蹄子时，你就在那里建立一座城市。”
weary hooves. And so Cadmus finds this cow, follows it to Beosha, where the cow duly lies down. And Cadmus knows that this is where he must found his city. And you can only found a city by offering a sacrifice to the gods. So he is preparing to sacrifice the cow to the gods. But to do that, first of all, he needs to purify himself. And so he looks for a spring, finds one. But horror, the spring is guarded by a giant, serpent sacred to ares, the god of war. Cadmus fights and kills the serpent. Athena then appears to him and says, take the teeth of this serpent, the dragon's teeth, and sew them, which Cadmus obediently does. And from these teeth sprout mighty warriors, who are known as the spartoy,
于是卡德穆斯找到了这头母牛，一路跟着它来到维奥蒂亚，母牛恰好在那里躺了下来。卡德穆斯知道这就是他必须建立城市的地方。而建立城市的前提是向神明献祭。因此他正准备将母牛献祭给神明。但在那之前，他首先需要净化自己。于是他寻找泉水并找到了一个。然而可怕的是，这眼泉水由一条属于战神阿瑞斯的巨大毒蛇守卫着。卡德穆斯与毒蛇搏斗并杀死了它。雅典娜随后出现在他面前说：“拿走这条蛇的牙齿，也就是龙牙，把它们播种下去。”卡德穆斯听从了命令。从这些牙齿中长出了强大的勇士，他们被称为“斯巴托伊”，
which literally means the sewn ones. The spartoy are about to attack Cadmus when he reaches down for a stone and throws the stone into the middle of the assembled throng of the Spartoy. The Spartoy get furious about this. They all start attacking each other. They all get wiped out except for five. And these five surviving members of the Spartoy help Cadmus to build the citadel of his new city, which is called Thebes. And they father the city's five most distinguished dynasties. So the Thebans live in the city founded by Cadmus, which is why in that passage of Homer that you quoted at the beginning of this episode, they're called Cadmeans. And Thebes goes on to be a great city, doesn't it? It does. Yes.
字面意思就是“播种之人”。斯巴托伊正要攻击卡德穆斯，这时他弯腰捡起一块石头，把它扔进了聚集的斯巴托伊人群中间。斯巴托伊对此勃然大怒。他们开始互相攻击。除了五个人之外，其他人全部丧命。这五个幸存的斯巴托伊成员帮助卡德穆斯建造了他新城市的城堡，这座城市被称为底比斯。他们孕育了该市最显赫的五个家族。因此，底比斯人生活在由卡德穆斯建立的城市里，这就是为什么在你本集开头引用的荷马诗句中，他们被称为“卡德穆斯人”。底比斯后来成为了一座伟大的城市，不是吗？确实如此。是的。
What I don't understand is, so Cadmus killed this serpent, which was sacred to Ares. And so that was seen as poor form from Cadmus. Well, it is seen as poor form by Ares. Oh, by Ares. Okay. Right. So, I mean, poor form on Camus's part. So his descendants then carry this a bit of a curse. But what I don't understand is, surely this story was told by the Thebans themselves, because it's their origin myth. So why would they tell a story in which they look bad? The canonical accounts that we have are Athenian, and so we'll be looking at the implications of... So this is Athenian propaganda? Not entirely. I mean, clearly this is a very, very ancient story, and people from cities are prepared to tell bad things
我不太明白的是，卡德穆斯杀了这条属于阿瑞斯的毒蛇，这在当时被认为是不守规矩的表现吗？嗯，在阿瑞斯看来这确实是不守规矩。哦，在阿瑞斯看来。好吧。也就是说，从卡德穆斯底波的角度来看是不守规矩的。所以他的后代们便背负了某种诅咒。但我不明白的是，这个故事肯定是由底比斯人自己讲述的，因为这是他们的起源神话。那他们为什么要讲一个让自己看起来很糟糕的故事呢？我们所拥有的正统记载都是雅典人的视角，所以我们将探讨……所以这是雅典人的宣传？不完全是。我的意思是，很显然这是一个非常非常古老的故事，城市里的人们也准备好讲述关于他们祖先的负面事情。
about their ancestors. I mean, Cadmus is a hero, killing the serpent. is a great feat, but it's just bad luck that this serpent was sacred to ares. I mean, it's like Terracius striking the snakes that turn out to be sacred to hera. You never know when you're going to offend a god. That's part of the jeopardy. You know, it's like a kind of computer game where you pick up the wrong thing and what kinds of disasters happen. That's basically what's happened to Cadmus. Tom, you don't even, you don't play computer games. No, I don't. I'm trying to give a kind of, you know, populist spin on it. The ones I have, I kind of remember that thing happening. So the dynasty of Cadmus, for that reason, is under a kind
卡德穆斯是个英雄，杀死毒蛇是一个伟大的壮举，但这条蛇恰好属于阿瑞斯，这只能说是不幸。这就好比特瑞西亚斯击打那些后来证明属于赫拉的蛇一样。你永远不知道什么时候会惹恼神明。这也是其中的风险所在。你知道的，这就像某种电子游戏，如果你拿错了东西就会发生各种灾难。这基本上就是卡德穆斯遭遇的事情。汤姆，你甚至不玩电子游戏的。不，我不玩。我只是想给它加一点……你知道的，通俗化的解读。我玩过的游戏里，我倒是有点记得发生过类似的事情。因此，由于这个原因，卡德穆斯的家族一直笼罩在某种阴影之下，正如希腊神话中的王室家族通常那样。举个例子，俄狄浦斯就是卡德穆斯的双重后代。卡德穆斯的一个孩子是个叫阿加韦的女孩，她又生了一个叫彭透斯的儿子，我们将在下一集中听到他们的遭遇。
of shadow, as royal dynasties in Greek myths, invariably are. So Oedipus, for instance, is doubly descended from Cadmus. So one of Cadmus's children is a girl called Agave, and she in turn has a son who is called Pentheus, and we will be hearing what happens to them in the next episode. Oh, that's an exciting little hint. It's nothing good. Okay. So Pentheus has grandchildren, and we have met them. One of them is Jakasta, the mother or wife of Edipus and Crayon, Edipus's uncle, straight, brother-in-law.
哦，这是一个令人兴奋的小线索。没有什么是好结果的。好吧。彭透斯有孙辈，而我们已经见过他们了。其中一个就是伊俄卡斯忒，俄狄浦斯的母亲或妻子，还有克瑞翁，俄狄浦斯的舅舅兼大伯子。
Leus, Edipus's father, is also a descendant of Cadmus, and he's actually a very, very bad man. So when he was young, he had gone to the Peloponnese, and he had been employed by a king in the Peloponnese, to teach a prince called Chrysippus how to drive a chariot. And Laos had raped the young Chrysippus. And Laos is the first ever male rapist of a boy. And this is the man who in old age will be murdered in his chariot by his own son. So maybe an element of calmer there. So there are all kinds of horrors that have preceded the reign of Oedipus. And equally, there are lots of horrors that will follow it. So we have a fragment from an epic poem that was written shortly after the time of Homer and Hesiod.
俄狄浦斯的父亲拉伊俄斯也是卡德穆斯的后代，而且他实际上是一个非常非常糟糕的人。所以当他年轻的时候，他曾去过伯罗奔尼撒半岛，并在那里被一位伯罗奔尼撒国王雇佣，去教一位名叫克律西波斯的王子如何驾驶战车。而拉伊俄斯强暴了年轻的克律西波斯。拉伊俄斯是有史以来第一个强奸男孩的男性。这就是那个在晚年将被自己的亲生儿子在战车上谋杀的人。所以这其中也许带有某种业报的成分。因此，在俄狄浦斯统治之前已经发生过各种各样的恐怖事件。同样，在此之后也还会有很多恐怖事件。我们有一段史诗残篇，写于荷马和赫西奥德之后不久，
And it describes Oedipus laying a curse on his two sons, Polynices and Etiocles and these lines. He prayed to Zeus and the other immortals that by each other's hands, they would go down into Hades. So he's praying that Etichlis and Polyneses will kill each other. And so it comes to pass because according to this tradition, Etychles and Polyneses, after Oedipus has left Thebes, you know, blinded, they share the rule of Thebes, but it doesn't work out. Ethically succeeds in expelling Polynices from the city. Polyneses is furious about this, wants to have revenge. So he goes to Argos. He recruits a great army there, lots of heroes, and he appoints seven captains to lead the assault on Thebes, one for each of the city's
它描述了俄狄浦斯对他的两个儿子波吕尼克斯和厄忒克勒斯诅咒的这些诗句。他祈求宙斯和其他不朽的神明，让他们死于彼此之手，坠入冥界。所以他是在祈祷厄忒克勒斯和波吕尼克斯自相残杀。事情也的确如此发展，因为根据这一传统，在俄狄浦斯离开底比斯之后（当时他已经瞎了），他们共同统治底比斯，但结果并不顺利。厄忒克勒斯成功将波吕尼克斯驱逐出城。波吕尼克斯对此大发雷霆，想要报仇。于是他去了阿尔戈斯。他在那里招募了一支庞大的军队，里面有很多英雄，并任命了七位将领来领导对底比斯的进攻，为城市的七个城门各配备了一位将领。
seven gates. And all save one of these die in the great battle that then follows. And Etychle's and Polynice's meet in single combat and they kill each other. And so it is that Oedipus's curse is fulfilled. But even that is not the end of the bloodshed because a generation later, there is another mass bout of slaughter because Polynice's son, back in Argos, a guy called Fassander, recruits It's another army. The sons of the seven against Thieves, they rally to his cause, and they succeed where their fathers had failed, and they capture Thieves. And among these, so among one of the sons of the seven, is one of the most famous of
除了一个人之外，其余所有人在随后的那场大战中都阵亡了。厄忒克勒斯和波吕尼克斯在单打独斗中相遇并同归于尽。就这样，俄狄浦斯的诅咒应验了。但即便如此，流血事件仍未结束，因为一个世代之后，又爆发了一场大规模的屠杀。因为波吕尼克斯的儿子——回到了阿尔戈斯的阿德剌斯托斯——招募了另一支军队。七雄攻打底比斯的儿子们响应了他的号召，他们取得了父辈们未能成功的成就，攻占了底比斯。在这些人当中，也就是七雄的儿子之一，有一位最终在特洛伊平原上作战的、最著名的希腊勇士，这就是狄俄墨得斯，他出现在《伊利亚特》中，是奥德修斯的挚友。
the Greek warriors who ends up fighting on the plain of Troy, and this is Diomedes, who appears in the Iliad, and is the great friend of Odysseus. But we know about Odysseus, and we know about Troy and all of that stuff because of the Iliad. Greeks, however, I guess, would have known just as much about these battles for Thebes, but because those stories have not endured, they seem very obscure to us. Is that right? Yeah, the stories from Homer, the stories about the wars in front of the walls of Thebes, these are part of the common stock of literary material that people are familiar with,
我们知道奥德修斯，也知道特洛伊以及所有这些事情，是因为《伊利亚特》。然而，我想希腊人对这些争夺底比斯之战的了解也同样深刻，但因为那些故事没有流传下来，所以对我们来说它们显得非常晦涩。是这样吗？是的，来自荷马的故事，关于底比斯城下战争的故事，这些都是人们熟悉的文学素材的共同库存，
and definitely people in Athens know all about it. And so at the end of the 6th century BC, the Athenians invent this novel literary form called drama. The fact that you have not just Homer's epics, but you have all these stories that are told about Thieves. I mean, it makes it, you know, it's like an enormous quarry that they can get to work on and kind of extracting material for their plays. And so Sophocles is not the only great tragedian to have written on a Theban theme. there are two other great Athenian tragedians, Eeschylus and Euripides, and they do exactly the same.
而且雅典人对这一切绝对了如指掌。因此，在公元前6世纪末，雅典人发明了一种名为戏剧的新颖文学形式。不仅有荷马史诗，还有所有这些关于底比斯的传说。我的意思是，这使得它就像一个巨大的采石场，他们可以从中开采素材来创作自己的戏剧。因此，索福克勒斯并不是唯一一个以底比斯为主题进行创作的伟大悲剧作家，还有另外两位伟大的雅典悲剧作家埃斯库罗斯和欧里庇得斯，他们也做了完全相同的事情。
And I think the appeal of the story, aside from providing material for good plays, is twofold. And the first is that any play that makes the Thebans look bad is absolute catnip to the Athenians. The Athenians hate the Thebans. So Thebes and Athens are only 30 miles apart.
我认为这个故事的吸引力，除了为优秀的戏剧提供素材之外，有两个方面。第一个方面是，任何让底比斯人看起来很糟糕的戏剧对雅典人来说都是绝对不可抗拒的诱惑。雅典人痛恨底比斯人。所以底比斯和雅典相距只有30英里，
And because there's a history, isn't there, a massive bad blood between them. So the Thebans had actually invaded in 506 and tried to basically strangle the Athenian democracy at birth. And actually, this had been a massive moment in Athenian history because the Athenians won. And this was the sort of foundational moment of their new sort of political system, right? Their political experiment. So quite like the Battle of Valmy for the French revolutionaries, kind of marvellous. kind of marching out to defend their novel political system. They're exciting cannons or whatever it was.
而且它们之间有着一段历史，不是吗？它们之间有着深仇大恨。底比斯人实际上在公元前506年入侵过雅典，并试图从摇篮里彻底扼杀雅典的民主制度。事实上，这曾是雅典历史上一个重大的时刻，因为雅典人赢了。这也是他们新的政治系统、他们的政治实验的某种奠基时刻，对吧？就像法国大革命时期的瓦尔密战役一样，非常精彩。他们气势汹汹地出征去保卫他们新颖的政治体系，带着令人兴奋的大炮或诸如此类的东西。
Yes. But the Athenians defeat the Thebans, and this is seen as the foundational moment where the democracy is secured. And then in 480, when the Persians invade, again, the Thebans block their copybook by siding with the Persians rather than with the alliance between Athens and Sparta, because the Thebans hate the Athenians much more than they fear the Persians. And then in 431, when this great war breaks out between Athens and Sparta, the first engagement in that war isn't actually between the Athenians and the Spartans is between the Athenians and the Thebans.
是的。但雅典人击败了底比斯人，这被视为民主制得以稳固的奠基时刻。然后在公元前480年，当波斯人入侵时，底比斯人再次大肆抹黑自己，他们选择站在波斯人一边，而不是站在雅典与斯巴达的联盟一边，因为底比斯人恨雅典人远胜于他们畏惧波斯人。接着在公元前431年，当雅典和斯巴达之间爆发这场大战时，这场战争中的第一次交锋实际上并不是在雅典人和斯巴达人之间，而是在雅典人和底比斯人之间。
And so when Thebes is portrayed on the Athenian stage as this sink of impiety and crime and incest and, you know, fratricide and so on. Obviously, the element of propaganda there is very strong, because the Sophocles plays and all the plays, people are not going to see them in the way that we would go. People are not going there to take in a show, something like that. Paul Cartlidge, who's written brilliantly, not just on Athens, but on Thebes as well. He describes this festival of drama as a festival of democratic liberation. The idea that the democracy has held its independence against Theban invasion is an important aspect of what people are expecting to see, kind of illustrated on the stage. And it's a massive civic occasion. You have maybe, the highest estimate would be 15,000 people attending it, which would be maybe half the entire citizen body of Athens, with I guess the sole exception of the Olympic Games.
因此，当底比斯在雅典舞台上被描绘成这样一个充满不虔诚、犯罪、乱伦、骨肉相残等罪恶的渊薮时，显而易见，其中的政治宣传色彩非常强烈，因为索福克勒斯的戏剧以及所有的戏剧，人们去观看它们的方式和我们今天去看戏是不一样的。人们去那里并不是为了单纯看一场演出之类的。保罗·卡特利奇（Paul Cartlidge）不仅对雅典，对底比斯也作出了极其精彩的著作，他将这场戏剧节描述为“民主解放的节日”。民主制在底比斯的入侵面前保住了独立，这种理念是人们期望在舞台上看到生动呈现的重要方面。这是一个盛大的公民庆典。你可能会有——最高估计会有15,000人出席，这大概占了雅典全体公民的一半，大概除了奥运会之外，
It would be the largest single gathering of citizens anywhere in the Greek world. And, you know, it is a celebration of the democracy, of Athens, and of the relationship that Athens and her citizens have with the gods. And so that is a crucial part of it. And sometimes the propagandistic element of tragedy is very, very overt. So there is another play that Sophocles wrote about Edipus, and it was the very last one he wrote. And in it, Sophocles shows the very aged Oedipus, so he's still in exile from Thieves, being given sanctuary from his native city by the Athenians. And the place of his refuge and ultimately of his grave is a village in Attica called Colonos, which was Sophocles' own birthplace. And before he dies, Edipus promises
这将是希腊世界任何地方规模最大的单一公民集会。而且，你知道的，这是对民主制、对雅典以及雅典及其公民与神明之间关系的庆祝。所以这是其中至关重要的一部分。有时悲剧中的政治宣传色彩非常非常公开。索福克勒斯还写过另一部关于俄狄浦斯的戏剧，这也是他写的最后一部剧。在剧中，索福克勒斯展现了年迈的俄狄浦斯——此时他仍被流放于底比斯之外——从他的故乡城市获得了雅典人的庇护。他避难并最终安葬的地方是阿提卡的一个村庄，名叫科洛诺斯，这也是索福克勒斯自己的出生地。在他死前，俄狄浦斯向雅典人承诺，
the Athenians that he will provide protection to them. You know, as a dead hero, his spirit will quote Sophocles will provide the Athenians with a defense a bulwark stronger than many shields and spears of massed allies and this play deposed colonists was Sophocles' last and it was
他将为他们提供庇护。你知道的，作为一个死去的英雄，他的灵魂将——引用索福克勒斯的话——为雅典人提供防御，提供一个比大批盟友的盾牌和长矛更坚固的壁垒。这部《在科洛诺斯的俄狄浦斯》是索福克勒斯的最后一部作品，它是在
produced posthumously in 401 BC four years after Sophocles had died and by this time the great war with Sparta was over and Athens had been defeated and so it's not surprising I think that Sophocles against that backdrop, as kind of almost his last will and testament, would have written for his
公元前401年索福克勒斯去世四年后 posthumously（死后）上演的。此时与斯巴达的大战已经结束，雅典已经战胜了……哦不，雅典已经被击败了。所以我想这并不令人意外，在这样的背景下，索福克勒斯几乎作为他最后的遗嘱，为他的同胞们创作了一部这样的戏剧：其中的俄狄浦斯传说为雅典人提供了一个充满希望和安慰的信息。但俄狄浦斯的故事并不仅仅是政治宣传，对吧？我完全同意你的看法，里面确实有反底比斯的政治宣传成分。但当你去看这场戏，或者当你阅读它时，如果你读到一个真正优秀的译本，你会发现它具有一种情感上的强度、力量和某种深刻性，依然能够触动你，正如它触动了西格蒙德·弗洛伊德一样。我的意思是，你不需要成为一个彻底的弗洛伊德主义者也能看出它具有某种普遍性。
fellow citizens, a play in which the legend of Oedipus offers the Athenians a message of hope and reassurance. But it's not just propaganda, though, is it, the Oedipus story? I completely take your point there's kind of anti-feebun propaganda to it. But when you go to see the play, or if you read it, if you read a really good translation, you know, it has an emotional, intensity and a power and a kind of profundity that still speaks to you, I mean, as it spoke to Sigmund Freud. I mean, it's not, you don't have to be a complete Freudian to see that there has a kind, there is a kind of universality to it. Yeah, and I think that if the Athenians had just used, you know, their great festival of drama to say, aren't we brilliant? You know,
是的，我认为如果雅典人只是用他们伟大的戏剧节来宣扬“难道我们不 brilliant（才华横溢）吗？难道底比斯人不可恶吗？”，那么今天就没有人会觉得雅典悲剧的杰作有任何感人或令人不安的地方了。你说得绝对没错，比如说，俄狄浦斯远不止是一场针对底比斯的得分练习。因为你在其中看到的是一位剧作家，他非常大胆，甚至可以说是无所畏惧地对他的最基本信念进行压力测试。毫无疑问，他极其尊敬神明。他以希腊人所称的“优萨巴亚”（Yusabaya，即虔诚）的品质而闻名，他有着极高的虔诚，对神明充满奉献。同样地，作为一位汲取伟大杰作（特别是荷马，还有讨论底比斯历史的史诗）的诗人，他很乐意去调整它、改造它、塑造它以满足自己的需求，但他不能完全抛弃它。他对来自过去的这种遗产有着太多的敬意。因此，正如你在《奥德赛》中读到的那段话，当荷马将乱伦和俄狄浦斯统治时期的恐怖描述为荷马所谓的“神明可怕计划”的表达时，索福克勒斯觉得这是他有责任去尊重的框架。但正如我们所见，他并没有糟蹋它。我的意思是，他将其中的紧张气氛拉升到了极其痛苦的程度。正因为俄狄浦斯被塑造成一个侦探的角色，观众比索福克勒斯如果不选择将它写成一部悬疑剧的话，会更加全神贯注地去体会俄狄浦斯发现真相时的恐怖感。
aren't the Theban's awful? Then no one today would find the masterpieces of Athenian tragedy in any way moving or unsettling. And you're absolutely right that, say, Oedipus is much more than just an exercise in point scoring against Thieves. Because what you see in it, I think, is a playwright who is kind of very, very boldly, fearlessly almost, stress testing his most fundamental conviction. There is no doubt he hugely respected the gods. He was, he was famous for his his quality of Yusabaya, as the Greeks called it, his piety, his devotion to the gods. Equally, as a poet who is drawing on the great masterpieces, particularly Homer, but also the
索福克勒斯刻意让俄狄浦斯发现真相所带来的冲击尽可能地骇人听闻。因此，我们在看完这部剧时毫无疑问地确信：俄狄浦斯犯下弑父乱伦的罪行时完全是无意识的，而且这一切都是在顺从神明的计划。但同样地，我们也没有丝毫怀疑，他的冒犯触犯了那些永恒、不朽且神圣的法律。索福克勒斯将这些法律描述为“生于天堂清澈的以太中，唯有奥林匹斯是其之父，凡人的凡俗之物从未触及过它们，遗忘也永远无法使它们陷入沉睡。”因此，这种恐惧其实是永恒神圣法则的体现，而所有凡人都注定要对其保持敬畏。
epics talking about Theban history, he is happy to kind of tweak it, to adapt it, to shape it, to his own needs, but he can't jettison it completely. He has too much respect for that kind of legacy from the past. And so when in the Odyssey, that passage that you read, Homer describes the incest and the horrors of Oedipus's reign as the expression of what Homer calls the God's dire plan. This is a framing that Sophocles feels duty bound to honour. But as we've seen, he doesn't dishonour it. I mean, he ratchets the tension of it up to a completely excruciating degree. And because Edipus is shown playing the detective, the audience comes to share in the horror of Edipus's discovery far more intently than if Sophocles had opted not to write as a kind of
是的。但与此同时，我们又对俄狄浦斯感到绝望般的同情，因为我们认识到这其实并不是他的错，他是神明和那些他……我本来想说他不理解的法律的阶下囚。其实他理解，但他是一种宇宙必然性的阶下囚，在其中他仅仅是一个玩物、一个棋子。没错，尽管俄狄浦斯显然是个底比斯人，但他也是一个陷入可怕神明计划网罗中的凡人。坐在那里观看的雅典人深知这一点。
who done it. Sophocles is deliberately making the impact of Edipus's discovery as appalling as he possibly can. And so we finished the play in no doubt that Edipus had committed his crimes of parricide and incest, utterly unwittingly, and had done so in obedience to the plans of the gods. But equally, we're left in no doubt that his offence is against laws that are timeless and eternal and sacred. And Sophocles describes these laws as begotten in the clear ether of heaven, fathered by Olympus alone, nothing touched by the mortal is their parent, nor shall oblivion ever lull them to sleep. So the horror of it is the expression of timeless divine laws that all mortals are bound to honor.
他们知道自己不只是在看一个底比斯人。他们看到的是一个和他们一样的凡人。我认为索福克勒斯在《俄狄浦斯》中所做的是一件非常非常大胆的事，因为他经常通过他们的死敌底比斯这面棱镜，向同胞们巧妙地反思雅典身处何方、他们的政治秩序是如何运作的。你可以从索福克勒斯上演这部悲剧时雅典所面临的政治环境的回声中看出这一点。还记得是什么促使俄狄浦斯派遣信使去德尔斐的吗？这可以说是整场悲剧的导火索，那就是城市里正肆虐着一场瘟疫。
Yeah. But at the same time, we feel desperately sorry for Oedipus because we recognize this isn't really his fault, that he is the prisoner of the gods and of laws that he. I was going to say he doesn't understand. He does understand, but he's the prisoner of a kind of cosmic inevitability. in which he is merely a plaything, a porn. Right, and although Oedipus is obviously a Theban, he is also a mortal who is trapped in the toils of a terrifying divine plan. And the Athenians sitting there watching it, know this.
现在，他可能是从《伊利亚特》的开篇中获得这个灵感的，那里同样也有一场瘟疫。但我认为这不太可能，因为在《伊利亚特》中，瘟疫是在军队营地里肆虐的。这并不是《俄狄浦斯》中发生的事情。在《俄狄浦斯》中，瘟疫是在一座城市里肆虐的。这几乎可以肯定是公元前430年袭击雅典并在随后几年里年复一年卷土重来的那场可怕瘟疫的回音。我认为，假设这部剧是在公元前430年之后上演的，坐在台下观看的雅典人会立即被这种相似性所震撼。我认为还有另一个相似之处，它也作为一个幽灵般的存在隐藏在那里。因此，这部剧最著名的名字《俄狄浦斯王》（Oedipus Rex），其实模糊了一个事实，即在希腊语中它的名字是《俄狄浦斯·蒂拉诺斯》（Oedipus Tyrannos）——他并不是一个国王。
They know that they're not just watching Atheban. They're watching someone who is immortal as they are. And I think what Sofocles is doing in Oedipus is something very, very bold, because he's often. his fellow citizens, kind of subtle reflections on where Athens is, how their political order functions, through the prism of their oldest enemy, Thebes. And you can see this in the echoes of the political circumstances that Athens is facing at the time when Sophocles is putting on his tragedy. So remember what prompts Oedipus to send the messenger to Delphi, which kind of sets and train the whole tragedy, is the fact that there is a plague raging
所以我们的“暴君”（tyrant）一词就源于此。他并非严格意义上的恶霸暴君，而是一个对整座城市拥有专制般权力的人。你可以为了好事使用这种权力，也可以为了坏事使用它。这有点像罗马的独裁官吗？罗马的独裁官背后有一种法律许可的支持。而“蒂拉诺斯”则没有。俄狄浦斯之所以作为一个“蒂拉诺斯”来统治，是因为他击败了斯芬克斯，
through the city. Now, he might have got this from the opening of the Iliad, where likewise there is a plague. But I think it's unlikely, because in the Iliad, the plague is raging in an army encampment. This is not what is happening in Edipus. In Edipus, the plague is raging in a city. And this is almost certainly an echo of a terrible plague that had hit Athens in 49 BC kept returning year after year. I think, you know, assuming the play is staged after 49, Athenian sitting there watching it would immediately be struck by the parallel. There is another parallel, I think, that is also there as a ghostly presence. So the name by which his play is best known, Oedipus Rex, obscured. gears the fact that in Greece, the name is Oedipus Tyrannos is not a king.
他受到了同胞们的拥戴，他们希望他掌权，但他并不是像拉伊俄斯那样凭藉卡德穆斯的血统作为国王来统治——尽管事实上，正如后来证明的那样，他确实是卡德穆斯的后代。而此时的雅典也有一个类似的人物，
So our word tyrant comes from it. It's not exactly a tyrant, but it's someone who has an autocratic degree of power over the entire city. You can use that for good or we can use it for bad. It's a bit like a Roman dictator, maybe? A Roman dictator has a kind of legal sanction behind him. A tyrannos doesn't. And Oedipus is a man who rules as a tyrannos because he's defeated the Sphinx. he's hailed by his fellow citizens
那就是伯里克利，这位民主制的伟大领袖，在他的敌人看来，他就像是一个“蒂拉诺斯”。所以我想，其中的回响足以在第一次坐在那里观看《俄狄浦斯》的人心中唤起一种真正令人不安的反思，其核心本质就是：如果神明的法律与凡人城市的法律——甚至是一座像雅典这样如此虔诚于神明的城市（雅典是一座著名的笃信神明的城市）——如果这两套法律框架无法调和，那该怎么办？
they want him installed but he's not ruling as a king in the way that Laos had done by virtue of descent from Cadmus even though in fact as it turns out he deposes descended from Cadmus and there is a similar figure in Athens at this time
你认为这也反映了伯罗奔尼撒战争带来的政治动荡吗？我们当时正处于伯罗奔尼撒战争之中吗？是的，我们正处于伯罗奔尼撒战争期间。雅典输掉了这场战争，对吧？正是如此。所以我觉得这是一个非常非常令人不安的概念。人类生活的法律与统治天堂、由神明所规定的法律之间并不一定是相辅相成的，这个想法令人震惊。这是一个索福克勒斯在之前的戏剧中就已经沉思过的问题。这也是一部以底比斯为背景的戏剧。
Amatis Pericles the great leader of the democracy who is seen by his enemies as a kind of tyrannos so I think that the echoes there would have been sufficient to rouse in the guys who were sat there watching Oedipus for the first time, a really unsettling reflection, which essentially is, what if the laws of the gods and the laws of a mortal city, even a city as devoted to the gods as Athens
这部剧叫《安提戈涅》（Antigone）。它以俄狄浦斯与伊俄卡斯忒所生的两个女儿之一的名字命名。它的背景设定在俄狄浦斯被流放之后，以及俄狄浦斯的两个儿子——厄忒克勒斯和波吕尼克斯——之间的战争之后。还记得吗，波吕尼克斯曾率领七雄攻打底比斯，而厄忒克勒斯和波吕尼克斯在底比斯城墙前互相厮杀而死。索福克勒斯现存第一部以底比斯为背景的戏剧《安提戈涅》开场时，两个兄弟厄忒克勒斯和波吕尼克斯都死在了他们城市的城墙外。但只有厄忒克勒斯，因为他一直在保卫底比斯，才能得到妥善的安葬。
and Athens is a famously God-devoted city, what if these two frameworks of law cannot be reconcile. And do you think this also reflects the political turbulence, the Peloponnesian war? Are we in the middle of the Peloponnesian war at this point? Yes, we're in the Peloponnesian war. Which Athens loses, right? Exactly. So I think that's a very, very unsettling concept. The idea that the laws by which men live and the laws that govern the heavens and which are ordained by the gods, that they're not necessarily complementary. And it's an issue that Sophocles had already pondered in an earlier play. And this is one that had also taken Thebes as its setting.
这是由他们的舅舅、伊俄卡斯忒的兄弟克瑞翁下令的，他现在作为国王在统治。他说，波吕尼克斯因为带领外国军队攻打底比斯，所以不能得到妥善的安葬。他要被留下来当作狗和鸟的食物。他还说，此外，甚至连哀悼这位背叛祖国的人，都会给哀悼者带来死刑。因此，他以底比斯国王的身份颁布了这项法令。他是城中的法律仲裁者，但他的法令并未让底比斯所有人都觉得它是合法的。而对此感受最强烈的人，正是克瑞翁的侄女、俄狄浦斯的女儿安提戈涅。她公然违抗克瑞翁，在波吕尼克斯的尸体上撒土，这样他就能渡过冥河，
And this is a play called Antigone. And it's named after one of the two daughters that Oedipus had had with Jakasta. And it's set in the wake of Oedipus's exile and the war between Oedipus's two sons, Etychle's and Polyneses, who remember Polyneses had led the seven against Thebes and Etychles and Polyneses had died fighting one another in front of the walls of Thebes. And Antigone, Sophocles' first surviving play with a Theban setting opens with both brothers, Etychles and Polynices, dead before the walls of their city. But only Etychles, because he had been defending Thebes, is to be afforded proper burial.
到达冥界。在神话的早期版本中，她是一个非常非常边缘的人物。洛厄尔·埃德蒙森（Lowell Edmunds）写过一本关于俄狄浦斯的精彩著作，他将安提戈涅比作斯托帕德戏剧中的罗森克兰茨和吉尔登斯特恩——《哈姆雷特》中的配角，罗森克兰茨和吉尔登斯特恩
And this is decreed by Crayon, their uncle, the brother of Jakasta, who is now ruling his king. And he says, Polyneses, because he had brought a foreign army against Thebes, he is not to be given a proper burial. He's to be left as food for dogs and birds. And he says, furthermore, that even to mourn this traitor against his native city will mean death for whoever mourns him. So he issues this decree in his role as King of Thebes. He is the arbiter of the law in the city, but his edict does not satisfy everyone in Thebes that it is legal. And the person who feels this most strongly is Crayon's niece, Antigone, the daughter of Oedipus, who defies Creon and casts dust on Polynesi's corpse so that he will then be able to cross the sticks
却成为了悲剧的焦点。这是一种绝妙的方式，展示了安提戈涅在这场悲剧中的核心地位是多么地与众不同。安提戈涅彻底占据了舞台中心，她被带到了克瑞翁面前，并公开抗命：“我不相信你颁布的法律，你不过区区凡人，竟能凌驾于神明那些既无形又永恒的戒律之上。”
and reach Aedes. in earlier versions of the myth she'd been a very very marginal figure so Lowell Edmondson has written a wonderful book on Oedipus he compares her to Rosencranton Guildenstern in Stoppard's play the peripheral characters from Hamlet Rosencrantz and Guildenstern are dead
所以她在捍卫应该埋葬兄弟的神圣法律。而克瑞翁则在捍卫公民法律，也就是人类的法律。最终他赢了，对吧？因为这是一场悲剧，安提戈涅公然反抗他。嗯，他看起来像是赢了。她被……怎么说，砌进了自己的坟墓里。然后她上吊自尽了。她确实上吊自尽了。但克瑞翁也输了，因为本已与安提戈涅订婚的儿子自杀了。
become the focus of the tragedy it's a wonderful way of demonstrating how Antigone's centrality in this tragedy is something very, it seems to be very, very novel Antigone completely takes centre stage and she's brought before Crayon, and Antigone openly defies him. I do not believe your laws, you being only a man, sufficient to overrule divine ordinances, unwritten and unfailing as they are.
克瑞翁的王后也自杀了。所以在剧目结束时，毁灭是彻底而完全的。正如《俄狄浦斯》结尾那样，合唱队见证了这场悲剧。他们得出了显而易见的教训：幸福的核心在于智慧，而智慧的第一要务是绝不能冒犯神明。但是，你知道的，我认为鉴于降临在俄狄浦斯家族身上的彻底毁灭，以及曾认可这一切的神圣秩序，把这当作结局未免显得有些苍白无力。我认为索福克勒斯在做的是探讨那些流传下来的关于神明及其与英雄关系的故事中的矛盾，
So she's standing up for the divine law that you should bury your brother. And Crayon is standing up for the civic law, the law of man. And he wins, right, because it's a tragedy, Antigone defies him. well, he seems to win. She's, what, walled up in her tomb. So, and she hangs herself. She does hang herself. But Crayon loses as well, because his son, who'd been betrothed to Antigone, he commits suicide.
这些矛盾此前从未被如此毫不留情地揭露过。因此，索福克勒斯在《安提戈涅》中强调的是，本质上有两套法律框架：一套是属人的，它源自人类的立法者，并且因为被写成文字而存在。你可以去查阅它。另一套是神圣的。它没有作者，也无法被书写成文。而这对神明意味着什么呢？
And so does Crayon's queen. She kills herself. So the ruin by the end of the play is completely total. And you have a chorus who, as at the end of Oedipus, his witness is tragedy. And they draw the seeming lesson. The chief as part of happiness is wisdom, that and not to insult the gods. But, you know, I mean, I think it's hard in light of the utter devastation that has been visited on the house of Oedipus and of the divine order that had sanctioned it, that this is kind of inadequate as a resolution. And I think that what Sophocles is doing is exploring contradictions in the stories told of the gods and their relationship to the hero.
无论人类制定了什么法律，只要触犯了他们的法律框架，神明就会毁灭人类。在《安提戈涅》中，神明被描绘成既反复无常、同时又是神圣旨意的守护者。根据你的视角不同，他们可能显得冷酷无情或极其严厉。他们可能显得专断或完全公正。其中存在着巨大的张力，而悲剧本身无法解决这种张力。这就是为什么关于谁才是《安提戈涅》真正的主角会有这么多的争论。是安提戈涅吗？是克瑞翁吗？
that had never before been exposed so remorselessly. So what Sophocles is doing in Antigone is emphasizing that there are essentially two frameworks of law, that one is mortal, it derives from human legislators, and it exists because it has been written down. You can consult it. The other is divine. It lacks an author, and it cannot be put into writing. And the implications of this for the gods, who will...
我的意思是，谁是对的？也许根本没有人是对的。而我认为，这正是悲剧的力量所在。你可以想象，对于一个身处可怕战争、遭受瘟疫折磨的城市公民来说，这些确实是极其迫切的问题。是的，当然。因为如果他们的处境糟糕，难道不是因为这是神明的判决吗？因为他们在某种程度上触犯了禁忌，就像俄狄浦斯那样，而他们对此并不完全负有责任，对吧？
destroy humans no matter what laws they draw up if it offends their framework of laws. In Antigone, they are framed as being simultaneously kind of whimsical, but guardians of divine purpose. They are, you know, they could seem amoral or very sternly moral, depending on your perspective. They could seem arbitrary or wholly just. And there is a massive tension there that the tragedy is unable to resolve. And that's why there are so many arguments about who the hero is of Antigone. Is it Antigone? Is it Crayon?
他们像俄狄浦斯那样在不知情的情况下触犯了禁忌。完全如此。更深远的一层含义是——作为一个非常虔诚的人，索福克勒斯并没有过分纠结这一点——它其实引发了你在本系列开头提出的那个问题，那就是：如果神明颁布的法律与凡人制定的法律之间的紧张关系如此痛苦，那么有关神明的那些故事，有没有可能它们其实并非真实可靠的呢？
I mean, who is right? Maybe it's possible that neither are right. And that, I think, is the power of the tragedy. And you can only imagine that for the citizens of a city that is in a terrible war that is suffering from plague, you know, these are really, really pressing questions. Yeah, of course. Because if things are going badly for them, might that not be because this is the verdict of the gods? Because they have in some way transgressed as Oedipus did in a way for which they're not entirely responsible, right?
如果它们没有被写进经文里，而只是由人类写下来，并且存在着各种相互冲突的版本，那么这难道不暗示着它们其实是文学虚构，而非表达永恒的真理吗？
That they've transgressed without knowing it, as he did. Absolutely. And the further implication, which Sophocles as a very pious man, doesn't dwell on, is it kind of raises the question that you, you know, you began the series with, which is, well, if the tension between. between the laws given by the gods and the laws given by mortals is so excruciating. Is it possible that the stories that are told about the gods that they're not actually authentic? Yeah. If they're not written down in scripture, they're just written down by human beings and there are competing versions, might the implication of that not be that they are literary concoctions rather than expressing timeless truths?
他们可能在不知情的情况下触犯了禁忌，就像俄狄浦斯那样。完全正确。更深层的含义是——索福克勒斯作为极其虔诚的人，并未对此过多着墨——这实际上引出了你在系列节目开头提出的问题：如果神明颁布的法律与凡人制定的法律之间的冲突如此痛苦难耐，那么关于神明的那些传说有没有可能根本不是真实的？是的。如果它们没有被记载在经文中，而只是由人类书写，并且存在相互矛盾的版本，那么由此得出的含义难道不正是：它们不过是文学虚构，而非表达永恒的真理？
You know, we'll explore how many people kind of worry about this. I mean, I don't think that most people in the theatre watching Antigone or Oedipus or whatever are worrying particularly about this. I think one of the features of the Greek mind is the ability to kind of hold completely contradictory notions in their head at the same time. I don't think it's just the Greeks think everybody can do that. Yeah, it's not. But there are definitely people in the audience watching Sophocles plays and watching other tragedies and comedies as well who are, starting to worry about this question. And in our next episode, we will be looking at one of those people, and he is another great tragedian called Euripides, and we will be looking at one
你知道的，我们会探讨有多少人对此感到担忧。我的意思是，我不认为大多数在剧院观看《安提戈涅》或《俄狄浦斯》之类的观众会特别担心这个问题。我认为希腊人思维的一个特点是能够同时在脑海中容纳完全矛盾的概念。我不认为只有希腊人才这样，每个人都能做到。是的，确实如此。但观众中绝对有人在观看索福克勒斯的戏剧以及其他悲剧和喜剧时，开始担心这个问题。在下一期节目中，我们将关注其中一位人物，他是另一位伟大的悲剧作家，名叫欧里庇得斯，我们将探讨他的其中一部
of his plays, in particular a play called The Backeye, which features all kinds of frolics in woods and violent dismemberings and a spot of transvestism. Wow, that's so much to look forward to. If you're a club member, can you hear that right away, Tom? You absolutely can. Oh, that's good news. And what if you want to, you're not a member of the club, but you wanted to join the club. Where would you go?
戏剧，特别是名叫《巴克科斯女祭司》的剧作，其中包含树林里的各种嬉戏、暴力的肢体解体以及一点异装癖。哇，真是让人期待。如果你是俱乐部会员，你马上就能听到吗，汤姆？你绝对可以。哦，那真是好消息。如果你想加入俱乐部，但还不是会员，你应该去哪里？
You would go to the rest is history.com. Yeah, and loads of benefits, I understand. loads of amazing benefits, and a chat community, and everyone loves a chat community. Right, on that bombshell, we will return next week with more thrilling Greek myths. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
你可以访问therestis history.com。是的，我听说有很多福利。有大量惊人的福利，还有一个聊天社区，每个人都喜欢聊天社区。好了，带着这个重磅消息，我们下周将带着更多惊心动魄的希腊神话回归。再见。再见。
You are not luminous, Watson, but you are a conductor of light. Here they are. Dr. Mortimer, I presume. Yes, hi. John, Dr. John Watson. Who is your client? He was my client. Sir Charles Baskerville.
你并不发光，华生，但你是光导。他们来了。莫蒂默博士，我想是的。是的，你好。约翰，约翰·华生医生。你的当事人是谁？他曾经是我的当事人。查尔斯·巴斯克维尔爵士。
Keep reading. Ah, a local shepherd noted, I saw first that of the maid, Hugo Baskerville passed me thence on his black mare, and there behind him, running mute upon his track, such a hound of hell that God forbid should ever be at my heels. I wish I felt better in my mind about it. It's an ugly business once, an ugly, dangerous business.
继续读。啊，当地一个牧羊人记录道，我首先看到女仆的，雨果·巴斯克维尔骑着黑母马从我身旁经过，紧随其后，在它的足迹上默默奔跑着，上帝保佑千万别让这样一只地狱猎犬追上我。我对这件事感觉心里很不踏实。这是一桩丑恶的生意，一件丑恶而危险的生意。
And the more I see of it, the less I like it. I shall be very glad to have you back safe from sound in Baker Street Passport. Hello? Goalhanger presents. You're not Sherlock Holmes. I'm Henry Baskerville. From one of the biggest audio dramas of all time. Is it bother you?
而且我对它了解越多，就越不喜欢它。我很高兴能让你在贝克街安然无恙地回来，护照。喂？Goalhanger 出品。你不是歇洛克·福尔摩斯。我是亨利·巴斯克维尔。来自史上最大的广播剧之一。这困扰着你吗？
Like in a creepy kind of way? Like in, uh, there's an evil giant hound that likes the taste of Baskerville's kind of way. The seminal gothic novel by Arthur Conan Doyle. They're watching. Who? Who are watching? It's not safe. Rimp and Maya. I could just make out its pitch black form.
就像那种让人毛骨悚然的方式吗？就像，呃，有一只邪恶的巨型猎犬喜欢巴斯克维尔家族血统的那种方式。阿瑟·柯南·道尔的开创性哥特小说。他们在看着。谁？谁在看着？这不安全。林普和玛雅。我只能辨认出它漆黑的轮廓。
Welcome to deepest. Everything a hellish void. Darkest. And for this piercing yellow glow of eyes. Dark mark. What do you want? Of giant fans. No.
欢迎来到最深处。一切都是一片地狱般的虚空。最黑暗处。为此，有一双刺眼的黄色眼睛在发光。黑暗印记。你想要什么？巨型扇子。不。
Sherlock and Cole. The Hound of the Baskervilles. Listen now. Five stars, says the eye paper. Hugely popular, says the Guardian. A successful reinvention of Holmes for a younger generation, says the Times. Search Sherlock and Co. wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
歇洛克与公司。《巴斯克维尔的猎犬》。立即收听。《i报》评价五星。\u201c极受欢迎，\u201d《卫报》评价。\u201d\u201c为年轻一代对福尔摩斯进行了成功的重新演绎，\u201d《泰晤士报》评价。在您获取播客的任何地方搜索 \u201cSherlock and Co.\u201d。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。